so we knew
that there was at least one black lives
matter activist who
was as a part of the storming the
capital and now we get a lot more
information coming out on this guy
john sullivan who apparently now in
league in leaked videos
he's cheering we did it we did it he's
with some other reporter or videographer
they actually got invited on to cnn to
talk about what's happening and i
suppose they were claiming that they
were
you know just there in the capacity of
filming so anderson cooper has them on
and
tell us what's happened you've also got
other news outlets that interviewed this
guy
now it turns out after he's been
arrested i think he's been arrested he's
been charged
there's apparently evidence of him
screaming like i got a knife let's go
and like really getting into it and
people are being put off by it like he's
like do it do it let's go and we'll read
some of his quotes but uh
this guy was propped up by cnn i love it
my friends i really have to recommend
the latest freedom tunes video because
it's so good
it's basically a right-wing and
left-wing pundit screaming whenever a
riot happens on the other side
but i i know it's not entirely fair but
it is still funny freedom tunes is great
we have them on the show sometimes but
anyway the point is
here's this leftist being allowed to go
on cnn and talk about all this stuff
he was doing it he was one of the people
leading the charge and encouraging
people to do it
and then the media says there were no
you know leftists what they'll do is
they'll say no antifa
well the guy's not technically antifa
because they play it both ways and say
there is no antifa and then when it
comes down to us colloquially calling
someone antifa they'll say he's not part
of the
of antifa yeah okay we get it whatever
fits their narrative
now we can see it we got a lot more
though uh we got leaked video
from project veritas of jack dorsey in
his rather drone
way saying there's going to be a lot
more after this
a lot more censorship so basically i'm
talking about banning trump
and how more is coming and there's some
creepy stuff happening you know we had
this teenage girl
snitched on her parents and this is like
totally 1984 level stuff that we're
starting to see
so kind of depressing maybe we'll talk
about aliens because we have that pulled
up as well but then we have some uh
you know i don't know how relevant this
news is to to everybody but considering
we're talking about
the capital and we're talking about who
was who's getting arrested
we have a story on this personality who
worked for buzzfeed
his name's baked alaska many of you
probably know him he jumped bail
to go to dc and then he he skipped his
court
appearance afterwards and apparently
he's missing so he's been banned from
all these platforms which
i mean he was banned a long time ago and
now apparently his lawyers have no idea
where he is and the court's like
what's happened to this guy so from
buzzfeed
to working with malianopolis storming
the capital
and now being i guess a fugitive from
the law it's a crazy story
considering it worked for buzzfeed i
think it's particularly relevant because
we'll talk a bit about this but uh
before we get to get into everything
let's introduce some of our guests we
got uh once again one and only jorge
ventura's chillin
yeah hori ventura field correspondent
with the daily caller glad to be back
and uh just talk about all the madness
going on in our country right on yeah
you also you did a documentary
on the businesses that have been
destroyed in california so yeah so we
got a documentary on the restaurant
industry just
basically really struggling against big
government no help from the state and
uh me and sonic here actually you know
got to be on the ground and really tell
those stories so i know
we'll get a little bit more into that
but really important story and we're
just trying to focus on
the average american again yeah we're
going to have fun ragging on california
i've got an article from a while back
talking about all the failed policies of
california which will uh we'll add into
your experiences but
uh producer from the daily caller stock
nick you want yeah i'm sagnikbasu
and i'm the producer for daily caller i
decided to spend my holidays you know
not being in the dc bubble and walking
like
filming actual people in california who
like run local businesses and like see
what's up with them
and jorge has been like doing an amazing
job on the field covering all these
stories so i just wanted to fly over
change coast for a while and like you
know put put like shed
actual light on these people so we'll
get into all of it but just before we do
california failed state yes failings
yeah for sure
definitely failing definitely going
downwards i mean like people do not
trust
like the people who like rule over them
and like they can actually sense the
fact that there's like an
like aristocratic like indifference from
the people like from the governors
they like realize that they don't really
care and
like these lock down like measures like
not only like make no sense like banning
outdoor dining but on top of that when
they see their
governors like downing outside and stuff
like that there's like uh
yeah like there's like the hate just
goes to a different dimension
yeah and of course we got the one and
only luke caskey you know you know some
people say skid row
is the new main street and i think it
makes totally perfect sense hi
i'm an independent journalist that
produces content on the youtube channel
we are
change i am also a very very humble
t-shirt vendor
on we are change.org forward slash you
already got some crazy shirt on what is
what
this one this one celebrates my in past
emancipation from new york as i left it
as this is
the new york state flag but edited
towards uh
my uh kind of understanding of it and it
says f this place and it has
two of the people that are usually there
running away i love it
as i moved away from new york city and i
will never come back to that
family-friendly show also very bad place
yes
of course we got star patch let's press
on all the buttons i am here in the
corner pushing buttons
right on and we're gonna we're gonna get
everything before we do we now have
timcast.com set up so if you haven't
already go to timcast.com and become a
member
we will have probably our first members
only post coming up uh
probably tomorrow and it's gonna be
after we wrap up here we've got some
friends we're gonna hang out and it's
probably gonna be a bit ridiculous so
that'll be up for everybody who becomes
a member we really need this uh the
reason i'm pushing so hard for this is
because uh as many of you
may be aware maybe not facebook recently
terminated access to monetization for me
i've never cared for facebook or relied
on it heavily at all
and they've never actually paid me
anything anyway but it's the principle
of the matter
i violated no rules and they stripped me
out of the program why i reported on
what happened at the capitol
no calls for action in fact as you've
listened to me the entire like the past
week or so it's been condemnation
facebook didn't care they nuked a ton of
channels so it was
obvious at a certain point when we
started putting the site together that
we needed to create a base for our you
know
the people who love the show and love we
work love the work we do because if we
get the acts from youtube or whatever we
want i want to at least try to keep
things going i know i often say
that if i get banned i'll just go down
by the river well you know
kind it mostly true but i'll at least
try not to be
entirely removed from the internet so
again timcast.com
sign up become a member but also you'll
notice if you go to the site there's a
shop button
when you click that you'll be brought to
a store where there now is
a t-shirt which reads i am a gorilla i
know everybody really wanted it
the the chat was just filled with people
posting guerrilla emojis
non-stop for months it's been months now
hasn't it
it's been months since since alex jones
came here and told everyone that he was
a gorilla
and everybody really wanted the shirt or
or just this was the meme
i made the shirt it is the fastest
selling shirt we've ever put up it's
crazy
so we're going to do a special edition
very soon of him wearing a tinfoil hat
that will only be available for like one
week and then we're gonna take it down
yeah so definitely go to tempest.com
you go to shop if you want to buy the
iama gorilla t-shirt but let's talk
about this first story
and and what's what's interesting about
this is cnn
platforming these people how about that
daily caller reports feds
charge left-wing activists who filmed
shooting of trump supporter at capital
they say federal prosecutors on thursday
announced charges against john sullivan
a self-described left-wing activist who
recorded the fatal police shooting of a
trump supporter inside the u.s capitol
last week
sullivan the founder of a group called
insurgents usa
which formed in the aftermath of the
death of george floyd is charged with
illegally entering the capital
civil disorder and violent or disorderly
conduct on capitol grounds
sullivan faces separate charges for
rioting and criminal mischief in
connection with an incident in provo
utah
on june 30th where a person was shot and
injured during a protest against police
brutality
for those that aren't familiar a car was
driving down the road and some
black lives matter dude runs up and just
shoots him for no reason
crazy stuff he was one of the organizers
they say an fbi affidavit
issued against sullivan on thursday
cites comments he made on video he
recorded during the capital breach
sullivan told fbi agents as well as
members of the media that he showed up
at the capitol to document the
activities of trump supporters who were
protesting the results of the
presidential election
but the fbi affidavit indicates sullivan
was acting more as an
uh more as an active participant in the
riots as a uh
then as a journalist here's the best
part here's what i want to show you got
this clip right here
mike cernovich tweets this out i can't
stop laughing sorry i know it's
it's all a scare a scared time but this
is just too much
you have this image of anderson cooper
bringing these people on his show
to ask about what's going on that's
interesting
i was told the people who stormed that
building were domestic terrorists
cnn is putting these domestic terrorists
on their tv to espouse their deranged
views that's incredible from these
quotes it gets really interesting
apparently he said let me see uh i'll
read this one
he said quote there are so many people
let's go this s is ours f yeah he is
heard saying in video
we accomplished this this s we did this
together f yeah
we are all part of the history this
history let's burn this
s down these are quotes from the dude
that cnn had on tv
wow he was filmed as a capital police
officer shot trump supporter
ashley babbitt as she attempted to enter
the barricaded section now
there's another interview that was put
up by the epic times where one reporter
said
he kept saying over and over again she's
dead and there were people saying no no
we can save her we can save her and he
goes no she's dead
and so what she was saying this
journalist is that she thinks he was
trying to enrage the trump supporters so
that they would take out some action
like
this would be a catalyst or something in
an interview with cnn's anderson cooper
hours after the fatal shooting sullivan
acknowledged he was not a trump
supporter but denied instigating the
rioters who stormed the capitol
i don't want to see people get hurt
unnecessarily he told cooper
some trump supporters have pointed to
sullivan's presence in the capital to
claim the left-wing active
that left-wing activists have served as
agent provocateurs egging on trump
supporters
to break into the capital and commit
violence um i think that's confirmed at
this point
and cnn did no vetting and put this guy
on tv bravo
now i'll be i'll be i'll be real with
all you guys i'm actually fine with him
being on the tv show him
being interviewed if you've got someone
who's a participant journalist should
interview them why did you do it what's
happening the problem
they didn't vet this guy he clearly lied
he was instigating he was a part of it
i've even seen a photo i don't know if
it was actually from the event but it's
like
it looks like it's him wearing a trump
hat and he's talking about how he's
infiltrating
and he's gonna he's gonna play a role it
seems like maybe this dude's real intent
was to
rile up trump supporters so that they
would be falsely accused or not not
falsely killed but that's so that they
would do something really bad
and then boom right there on tv sure
enough he goes on cnn
and what does he say oh yeah look at
everything they were doing it's not not
us
yeah i watched that interview and it's
just funny
now that we're talking about it it's
like cnn interviewed him like if he was
actually like a journalist for a media
company it was like
it's like cnn if you want a reports
perspective on the ground there's
tons of you know ground reporters that
were on the ground you could have
grabbed
someone from the ap from the reuters
like anywhere i got i got
to i got to say something i got to say
something they took
one of the people they claim as a
domestic terrorist they keep saying
right
they put him on tv with this woman now
this woman there's a video where she's
like
we did it we did it and he goes this is
going to be the best film you've ever
made and they're like yeah and she goes
are you recording this he goes i'll
delete it i'll delete it he's clearly
egging them on
cnn says he was there in a doc in a in
the capacity to document sitting across
from us over on a bean bag is richie
mcginnis was chilling
and the new york times called him a
rioter who punched the window
and richie's a journal you guys are
journalists working for a news
organization
with press credentials for the capitol
building what do we get
the new york times falsely calls richie
a rioter who punched the glasses
never even happened they just make it up
what do they do they make it up
they said oh this guy punched the window
and they're like just publish it
and then this guy who's actually there
saying yes let's do this burn it down
cnn's like interesting from a
videographer and photographer
this is what we you know what man life
is parody
it's a joke it definitely highlights how
horrible the mainstream media is but
also
a lot of questions about you know what
actually happened there of course a lot
of people are going to be exposing their
theories but
it's also important to note that ford
fisher just found a twitter tread
thread about this guy from allegedly
left-wing
uh people in seattle from november of
last year talking about how people in
the activist community
in seattle think that he might be uh
infiltrator or an agent provocateur
those are the exact words from a
thread going all the way back in
november specifically about this same
john sullivan individual who is this guy
so i i got a thread from max blumenthal
now max is a leftist and he goes
through a bus this this big threat about
this guy john sullivan
saying that he was egging things on as
it was happening
he says now uh now he's exhibit a in
right-wing claims that antifa instigated
the riot
but i think is where the nuance comes in
i mean this this dude john sullivan
was rejected by black lives matter was
rejected by
even antifa in seattle and here he is
on the ground at the capitol pretending
to be a trump supporter or what
pretended to be a journalist
so this is weird maybe it really just
comes down to some
crazy crackbot instigator who wants to
watch the world burn
maybe he's actually a leftist he's
certainly not a trump supporter
i mean especially but it could be that
um
he's a leftist who he organized you know
this this provo protest for black lives
matter
yeah maybe he may be he might be
aggressive and he may be a provocateur
but it definitely seems like he's a
leftist like yeah and it was odd too
because
i was even watching some news from utah
like their local news stations also
were interviewing john like if he was
like a field correspondent for someone
so
this whole thing is just odd how it
happened but
you know uh it's kind of funny because
it's like us at the daily caller we've
been covering riots the whole summer and
uh
cnn never never hit us up for an
interview and they you know want to know
our perspective from the ground the
funny thing is when the new york times
labeled ritchie a rioter
the correction they put out said what
did they say a right-wing outlet or
something
a right-wing daily caller yeah or
right-wing like that's the that's the
most bothersome part it's like not only
do you like not concede the fact that
you guys were wrong
and like misleading and like potentially
putting someone else's reputation in
like
life words of harm like the correction
you run is like making sure that
he's more damaged by telling that oh all
right being a reporter
was inside the capital you know what
that means why don't they say left-wing
reporter for like jim acosta you know
you know what yeah right right right
with credentials yeah they could have
said
we made a mistake it was a journal the
worst part is like it's not like they do
not know who richie mcginnis is like
they use their reporting for kenosha
which was like invaluable to like most
extent and
it no no it shows they did know the
groundwork they
did they didn't google search they
didn't ask who this guy was
they just said it's a writer that's the
problem that's the problem with
mainstream media like they are so
married to their narrative yeah it
doesn't really matter what comes in wait
well they're so married to the narrative
that they'll put one of the people who
stormed the capital and cheered it on
on the news on the news yeah as a
journalist and then the new york times
will call the journalist a rioter who
it's just and you know what's the best
part of it tim is cnn it's not gonna
even update a story like hey guys
we just interviewed a writer we just
found out this is the church they don't
even update everything
that was probably wrong but this is
important according to the fbi the
initial reports that i'm seeing right
now this
john sullivan allegedly told the police
officers to stand down in the speaker's
lobby and then he quote agitated the
crowd to attack the doors and windows
when he filmed
at the moment when ashley babbitt was
shot he told the cops to stand down
this is according uh yeah yeah according
to some initial reports i'm seeing here
i wasn't able to verify that this is
allegedly according to the fbi i needed
a few more minutes to kind of fact check
this
uh i'll send you the link right now
there's a justice.gov document
i got it i will okay here we go uh in
the fbi affidavit they say
several times during the video sullivan
encounters law enforcement officers who
are trying to prevent further
advancement through the building
by those who entered unlawfully in at
least two encounters sullivan can be
heard on video arguing with officers
telling them to stand down
so that they do not get hurt among other
things sullivan can be heard telling
officers you are putting yourself in
harm's way
the people have spoken and there are too
many people you gotta stand down
the people out there that tried to do
that as they got hurt
i saw it i'm caring about you hey what's
wrong with that and that's when and
that's when ashley babbitt was shot and
killed that's another important aspect
here because he's inciting at the exact
moment where it was
the worst scenario that unfolded that
could have gone
very much more haywire a lot more people
could have got hurt
and were extremely extremely lucky that
that situation
just led to one's death because it
because it could have easily been that
was isolated
they were lucky about it it could have
easily led to a whole massacre and a
whole disaster
that luckily didn't i think this guy is
just like the joker i don't think he
really cares about much i mean reading
about him
the left is like nah dude look at this
guy and i'm kind of like i'm seeing what
they're saying he just wants to
yeah exactly yeah he wants to watch the
world burn that's his thing what is
going on there's a cat running
going crazy i'm sorry i tried the cat
came in here and started running around
anyway back to the important news
this is the bonus content you've all
been waiting for mr johnson hey
he's just there to document guys he's
just there to document
she's doing her job it's all right so
what was going on i we're distracted by
it yeah we're going to
be talking about the fbi rich richie's
now crawling
you could stand up and get the cat it's
fine
okay go there we go so but now but but
now
we're getting a little bit more
information on some of the arrests uh
that are that are coming out
i believe uh we had like two virginia
state officers involved
and yeah yeah yeah there were some
apparently some cops were hiding them
one cop put on a magazine and told them
where to go that's insane yeah so this
is an investigation so when i hear about
you know they're locking down dc like 20
000 national guard or whatever and
they're going to shut down the national
mall
i think there's legit like threats
because this is
this stuff that's happening with the
sixth the electoral college that was
trump being like let's go peacefully
march
i imagine there's actual people who are
fired up and
and crazy and the sixth wasn't their day
so i'm i'm i'm i'm hoping they keep
their security tight when we get through
this peacefully
another thing to really consider here
was that there was a lot of arrests made
of military personnel
so that's another huge factor here and
we had that letter that we talked about
in yesterday's podcast
about the military sending out notices
that it was joe biden that won the
election
it's not a contested election and now
there's even a photo going around with
one of the soldiers
laying down and reading atlas shrugged
inside of the capitol
that's getting the rounds on social
media and people are betting
how long it's going to take for this uh
soldier to be kicked out of the capital
as there's congress members demanding
that the military there
are vetted to make sure that they don't
believe in donald trump and or
our right-wingers he read atlas shrugged
that confirms it he's if he's far right
that's it somebody tweeted this there's
a viral tweet it was on uh it was on
reddit too
it said uh it says far right it shows
kyle written house and then it says
right and it shows nancy pelosi and it
says center and it's aoc
oh my gosh oh that was the dumbest thing
ever yes then it says left and it says
you know leadership not found and they
were like the overton window has shifted
so far to the right
that there is no left leadership in this
country what and it's like
bro if you think aoc is a centrist
you need to you need to turn the
internet off you need to just go outside
for a couple days
and not go online not read the news and
just like you know
do some jobs that's what goes to show
like how much power the left has over
the media it's like
they have been able to shift the overton
min overton window so efficiently
and without people like noticing it like
that they do it so gradually
and it becomes like risky to say like
normal things which people used to
believe in like two years ago so here's
the thing
the reason why this guy doesn't get it
the reason why there's no
in his mind left leadership is because
if you actually
realign the overton window properly you
can't go further left than ocasio-cortez
exactly what i was going to say now
you can you can argue authoritarianism
libertarianism you can you can argue her
policies aren't effective enough or
she's not an effective leader
but she's a literal socialist member of
the democratic socialists of america
so let's let's just do this if we're
talking about the economic scale left
versus right
she's a socialist socialism is is
literally the far left end of the
spectrum whereas laissez-faire
capitalism is the far right
if she was you know like a
social democrat like denmark where you
have a capitalist system
but a large welfare state you could
argue she's just a leftist no she's far
left
and i'm not saying that disparagingly
she is if you want to talk culturally
left versus right which is far left
would be progressive
and far right would be traditionalist
aoc is
far far left like intersectional
proposing bills on far left ultra woke
ultra progressivism she's i don't want
to pretend like she's
the furthest left possible because
there's probably an argument there about
what constitutes as far left you can go
but when you're a socialist who is ultra
woke you've got you've got the cultural
spectrum and the economic economic
spectrum
and considering where she stands
relative to everyone else in the country
she's probably the furthest left
politician we actually have in office
well i was gonna say tim do you think
that that that picture came from because
i know right now the
the progressive movement of the
democratic party they're really actually
upset with like the
with the squad because they didn't do
like the force the vote on the medicare
for all
right you think that's that's an issue
because i know i'm actually seeing like
you know obviously like jimmy dore and
other progressives now come out and say
aoc is actually not even one of us you
know she's now part of the establishment
so do you think that's where it's coming
from
um you can uh argue that she's an
effective
leader right you know she says she wants
medicare for all but this is not the way
she don't force a vote she won't even
right but then the question is
her being far left is a question of what
she believes and advocates for
just because she was like my strategy is
different doesn't mean she's not far
left so there are people who try to
argue she's not really a leftist
that she's a careerist and it's
exemplified by the fact that she voted
for pelosi and refused to stand up
and i'm like dude if a guy came out and
advocated for
fascism but then voted for republicans
you'd still call him a fascist you know
what i mean you'd be the guy's clearly a
fascist
she's clearly a socialist she's clearly
far left she just supports democrats as
a means to an end
if we could have a political scale i
wish it could be if you believe in
freedom or if you're an authoritarian
and and those those are the biggest ones
because when you look at aoc she's
talking about putting trump supporters
on list
she's calling for the banning of parlor
she's calling for the reigning in of
media
and the media environment that's total
totalitarian
big government and and to me the most
important spectrum that gets
overshadowed is if you believe in
freedom or if you believe in total
government
and she in my opinion believes in total
government well so
that's that's the thing right if you
look at someone like her
she's an authoritarian yeah they'll tell
you she's not but she's on the right
side of the aisle though that's what
that's why that's why people like media
doesn't like distinct distinguish
between that like she's on the left-hand
side
she's on the left but like from that
from her perspective she thinks that
like locking down from supporters or
anyone who has walked in that garment is
okay but
and the media allows that only because
she's advocating that from the left
so authority authoritarianism doesn't
matter because she's advocating it right
from the left-hand side of the aisle and
well and so
i think the left fundamentally many of
these younger leftists don't understand
what authoritarianism means versus
libertarianism freedom versus authority
the
the hierarchical control versus the
decentralized you know system
aoc is definitely on the authoritarian
scale and so is bernie sanders for that
matter but they always show you this uh
uh
this political compass that shows bernie
and aoc on like libertarian left and i'm
like
no no no no you can't advocate for
banning private insurance and call that
libertarian
yeah you can argue for voting for a
cooperative system like if you were to
say
you know even if you were to argue for
universal health care there's still an
author
authority element in that i wouldn't
necessarily argue it's a it's overly
authoritarian
right but when you follow it up with and
then we're going to take away from you
now you're in the authoritarian spectrum
you're taking from people and then
you're so distributing it yeah well so
it's it's it's
it's a combination of the two right if
you
get universal health care i would argue
there's a path to that
that is not authoritarian it's very very
difficult because you're taking people's
resources
you're by force essentially but if it's
through a democratic process and a vote
then it's it's not authoritarian but
it's getting close to the line
exactly then coming afterwards and
saying we want to ban what you have now
okay that's that's definitely the
authority saying i know what's better
for you and you're not allowed to choose
and that's where your metric for that is
like if the means to your end
involves government power you're you're
the way you're doing it is probably
authoritarian
well they'll they won't admit it though
and that's why it's funny you see
someone like jimmy dore
jimmy dore's libertarian left and it's
he wants universal healthcare which is a
cooperative system
and he wants them to challenge the
machine the powers the establishment
he wants to challenge the authority
system to to
and you know his perspective force the
authority to relinquish the power
and then give it to the lower classes
that's like
how the left often views with what
they're doing i don't want to speak for
jimmy i really respect that i think it's
good dude i was gonna say but i mean is
aoc
does she even have any power in
washington because you know she came
into dc she's
supposed to be this young congresswoman
who's gonna break the democratic
establishment but
it seems now she's just become a
cognitive in the machine she votes for
nancy pelosi she really hasn't got
anything progressive
past so are we are we overblowing of how
powerful aoc is because
it seems like she's now a cognitive in
the machine she's playing the game
yeah look she'll come out on twitter and
be revolutionary but when it comes to
like voting
she's not but she's she was a freshman
congresswoman
she's not going to get anything done i
think she renamed some post offices and
that's but but that's not
that's what happens when you're in your
first term you're not going to have any
power or any
any leverage or any connections and so
you get what you get but
she's got what 12 million followers
jesus she's not going anywhere
she is sucking the money from the
democrats like trump did from the
republicans
now she might go somewhere democrats
might get rid of her
the republicans want to get rid of trump
because he's sucking up all the
donations not only that
after him all these corporate
corporations are like we're not going to
donate to these
republicans anymore right so now they're
like get rid of trump nah you can't
nope he's got to accept it well i would
actually disagree with you guys because
when we look at alexandria ocasio-cortez
she's in government she's a freshman
you know congresswoman so she's not
doing that much but culturally she's
doing a lot exactly
but she's playing the last of us and
she's exposing her ideas when she's
going on twitter when she's going and
ranting
on on live streams she gets millions of
views and everyone's listening to her
and she's the kind of
new thought leader of the left promoting
authoritarianism and making it trendy
it's trendy that the big corporations
control everything it's trendy and cool
that that there's someone that will
punish the bad guy
whoever that bad guy may be at any
moment in time based on our narrative
that changes and is absolutely bipolar
so so that
in that aspect we have to understand
huge huge power
and influence that that hasn't been
tested hasn't been
challenged effectively at all in my
opinion there's a nuanced argument i
would say
to say that she's not a leftist in that
she's just a tribal leftist
meaning she says things that will get
her clicks
get her more followers and it works it's
really easy to go to someone and say
vote for me and i'll fight for you why
because i am the true progressive
i'm gonna make them give you money how
would you like two thousand dollars cash
in your pocket vote for me
yeah that's that's called whispering
sweet nothings into a constituent's ear
that's kind of what andrew yang is doing
right now with his run in
new york city yeah but it works a lot of
people are
so desperate they're so downtrodden
they're so screwed over by the
government i mean when we look at the
actual issues that are that are
affecting us
failing wages uh the
de-industrialization the lack of jobs
the lack of ability to actually have
uh economic mobility in the united
states people are so
poor people are so downtrodden that
they're like yeah i'll take it just give
it to me just whatever i have to do
sure give me that two thousand dollars
and of course as as someone who doesn't
believe in government
there was still i have to admit this a
lot of individuals where that two
thousand dollars
would have actually made a big
difference in people's lives that would
have been so important for them
and and i believe in like anarchism i
don't believe in government doing
you know anything for anyone but you're
not a real anarchist luke because you're
not leftist anarchist
whatever it doesn't matter i'm kidding
you know but look but look
i i just want to touch what you said um
i think after the experience
with me and sonic in california like
talking to the restaurant industry it's
like when we're there it's like
we could see these these folks need the
two thousand dollars and
and they just need something and it's
just like from government there's
there's no urgency
and it's just we're just failing the
average american so now these
now these leftists could come in and say
here vote for me you get 2 000
reoccurring checks
i mean but listen listen you're right
these people need these checks
but how twisted is it that a dude walks
into your house and he takes your gallon
of milk out of your fridge
and he dumps it down the drain and then
you're like bro i need milk and he goes
all right all right tell you what
vote for me and i'll give you your i'll
give you milk it's like you took the
milk from me in the first place
dude king's in economics one-on-one like
if you break into someone's like break
someone's garage door like it's your job
to fix the garage door like the
government did this to the economy
it's their job to make sure that these
people have a safety net yeah but i mean
the problem is
it is the perfect scenario for the
government
they they create the dependence yeah and
then they're the they create the problem
and they're the only solution yeah they
give us power then we'll solve this
thing
we started the problem it's our fault
but don't worry if you vote for us
we'll fix it for you and they're gonna
make a lot worse by devaluing your
dollar collapsing the economy
and then the price of your your daily
items at the grocery store will go up
dramatically and you won't be able to
afford to live
the medical industry is already rigged
it's going to be even more rating
effectively yeah
it's even going to be more rigged with
companies like amazon coming into
the play here as they're trying to get
control of the healthcare market now
as amazon just recently teamed up with
warren buffett with berkshire
and jamie dimond of jp morgan to launch
a new health care company
so so when you look at this kind of
meglo
like monopoly huge conglomerate of a
of a glob that is amazon they've taken
over the book business they're
taking over their online retail business
they're they're taking over all the
lucrative
government contracts they're taking over
grocery stores and now they're trying to
take over
the health industry look it's okay
because they tweet black lives matter
luke
it's okay but hold on hold on let me
stop you guys
ragging on amazon yes what about this
think about this i remember when i was
growing up they were like how many banks
were there it's like you want to go to
the bank there are so many banks
well then by by just good fortune
bank of america bought up every single
bank yeah and so then it was like dude
you could walk a block and boom bank of
america so the atm was super easy to use
super convenient
how awesome was that so here's what i
think about imagine a future
where you don't get you open your phone
right you open your phone you get yeah a
hundred apps
i don't even know what's going on
there's so many apps i would like one
app we'll call it app
then think about you gotta go the doctor
i don't wanna think about what building
i have to go to
how about we just have one big building
called store and it'll be owned by jeff
bezos
and app will be owned by google and
it'll just do everything
right that's the future we're going to
head towards where there's one massive
conglomerate i'm joking for those that
people haven't gotten
through the facetiousness but the point
i'm making is uh
they're they're hyper monopolizing
everything into
single sources for everything where they
will be the provider
and then i want you to think about what
that future has in store for you when
you get banned by
app you can't order food you can't use
your map you're done
imagine if apple banned you from their
from their from from their iphone ios
they could yeah you don't own the
software they're licensing it to you on
your phone
people they can people don't question
aggregation of power monopoly
oligopolies if that
gives them convenience in their
day-to-day lives and that's the like
that's the problem like they like
they're using amazon they're using like
they're reading
like washington post but they're not
questioning the fact that this one
company gets to control so much
that if i fall out of line what will
happen to me these these you know people
don't get to
i love the naivety of these people who
think that
well jeff bezos can't force the
washington post to write
you know whatever so you know they're
editorially independent it's like oh
shut up dude
yeah yeah jeff bezos will just be like
oh
uh yeah i can't tell you what to write
but um yeah no budget this year yeah you
don't walk here anymore
yeah right and then not only that tim we
also have to think about the influence
of the washington post because now
journalists who are dying to get to the
washington post they're never going to
investigate amazon or they're never
going to
report on amazon truthfully because they
want to they want that washington post
job too so then you make other
you know all these other media and
journalists kind of just bend over to
you without even having to be at the
washington post either so that's
something that that's why it plays a
role too
the trump news cycle dominated for so
long because it was
not a threat to the establishment but it
gave them this
like narrative that they were fighting
the machine it was really fun to hear
from leftists when they'd say like
you know i i would talk about paul just
watson says you know conservatism is a
new counterculture
and it's punk rock apparently the most
punk rock song you could write would be
supporting the president because the
entirety of the cultural machine
is against him yeah and people but
that's not true he's the president and
i'm like yeah
who struggles to get any of his policies
done because the republicans don't even
like him
he hires and fires people faster than
anybody else we've ever seen and he's
really
locked up because of the mueller
investigation like the dude was pinned
down in a lot of ways
far from perfect but the point is just
because you're president doesn't mean
you control
anything right i mean you you do have a
lot of control trump was able to do a
lot of things
but i look now at aoc and if politics is
downstream from culture
trust me man give it 15 years and aoc is
going to be considered
they're going to call her conservative
she's going to be considered a moderate
democrat by the time she's like you know
in her 50s or 60s so like you don't
think
you don't think that she actually
believes that things she taught her
right now she is
you know she does what i'm saying is
that in how old is she now she's uh
twenty eight nine nine yeah she's like
no she's like 31 yeah yeah i think so in
in you know let's say
30 years universal health care
uh universal jobs guarantee all that
stuff she's talking about in that little
drawing thing she did
that will be considered yeah the
republicans are being excised
conservative values are gone and you
know it's a conservative's fault in a
lot of ways
i've had so many arguments with
conservatives about big tech censorship
over the past several years i remember
once i was when i was in milwaukee
i was talking to this guy and i said we
need to regulate big tech to protect
freedom speech freedom of speech and he
argued with me and i was like dude
if you want to sit here and argue with
me that we shouldn't regulate these
companies when i'm like the liberal
are arguing for this i'm just gonna
agree with you you know why it's not
my ideology getting purged from the
internet so by the time you've figured
out what's happening to your ideas and
your ideology
and your politics you'll be long gone
and i'll have been fighting to preserve
my politics and what i believe in so if
you're not smart enough to realize
what's happening
then you won't then then maybe your id
ideas don't deserve to exist anyway
yeah hey jack dorsey is more powerful
than the president of the united states
i think that that says it all
uh the good thing is i don't know if
it's a you know good thing but i think
it's an interesting concept is how
these other countries are now waking up
to this concept of what social media
in the united states and just the kind
of that reach between social media and
then big government here united states
no now other countries like wait a
minute
when it comes to election time we should
be banning the we should be banning the
facebook and twitter yeah
you gotta just did it yeah and they saw
like this if this american app can like
ban their own president we won't let
jack dorsey dictate what happens in
hours
in our democracy really quickly before
you go just just a funny it was a daily
uh
uh we have a guy named logan hall with
the daily caller and he tweeted he's
like uh
he's like hey facebook why don't you why
don't you go build your own country
yeah i said why don't you build your own
uganda yeah
yeah well this is important here i don't
know if we should maybe pull this up but
the mexican president just announced
that he's going to be
mounting an international campaign
against social media bans
so the mexican president right now is
saying that the first thing he's going
to do at the next upcoming g20 meetings
is to organize a proposal
where they will work together to of
course make sure that social media
companies cannot suspend
freedom of expression and he's actively
fighting for i never thought i would i
would
ever say this the mexican president is
actively fighting
for the speech of donald trump that's
great
what uh 2021's
this is a pretty big story let's do this
let's do this let's talk about what
veritas
just ended up um publishing yeah where
the story from breitbart project veritas
video shows twitter ceo jack dorsey
saying censorship is not quote
going away anytime soon it's interesting
i heard james o'keefe you know puts up
this video and he says
we got a recording of jack dorsey
speaking and i said man i wish it was
just
jack dorsey literally sitting there with
uh with his real voice going
now we're going to ban all of the
conservatives and they'll never speak
again
but in reality life isn't like that so
it's really just him going
so we're focused on this one account and
you know what we're seeing with these
other accounts
like q and on it's not going to stop
anytime soon but right now we're focused
on this one account
life's boring it really is you're not
going to hear some secret meeting
between you know jack dorsey
no he's like it's like he's on the phone
with cnn he's like i think we're going
to do the right thing
and ben trump all right have a good day
i just got off the phone
they believed everything no it's not
it's not like that jack is exactly like
he is
exactly like he speaks and it's the
banality of evil
it's him going there being like we're
doing the right thing to prevent
violence by
silencing 74 million people who are
extremely angry right now
and i know that they just stormed the
capitol and they were all extremely
angry and there was
several people who died and i think it's
the appropriate thing to make them
angrier
and and and prove exact everything they
believed is true
well tim i want to ask you when when you
did the the whole thing when you know
joe rogan had you on and you just kind
of like
came on and just pressed jack did you
leave that podcast was like hey
i think this guy might fix some things i
think he like considers some of the
things we're saying you're just like
no he's an oligarch and it is what it is
because we were talking about blockchain
technology
and you know there was talk about i
don't know if we talked about it on the
show there was talk about creating
a social media network that on the
blockchain so you can never ban anyone
and i was like dude that's a nightmarish
you know why because then when you're 16
and you post something really dumb
on the blockchain forever forever yeah
you can't get rid of it
yeah that's horrible so i'm like you
know people need but maybe that would
actually not that be
that bad of a thing because if everybody
was forced to realize we've all been
dumb kids
saying dumb things yeah then they'd be
like hey when you were 16 you said
before you say that i can see what you
said when you were 16. yeah how about we
just shut up
yeah it might it might actually end up
being a good thing but uh
no i think he's a he's a bad person and
um that was classic tim
that was good stuff just you just
drilling him in him having to be like oh
he had to bring like another twitter
person to like handle the questions
it was legendary well i mean because joe
and jack did it the first time and then
they
were both like we'd have a bigger
conversation about this no but like
following that he was talking about we
talked about the road to redemption
like if in the real world you could
murder somebody and you only go to
prison for 25 years you get let back out
with restrictions right
and i was like but you could say learn
to code on twitter and and be banned
from
life a little harsh don't you think and
so they jack was saying this is not what
like two years ago he's like we're gonna
have a
road to redemption people will be able
to come back we'll find a path to come
back on
and i was like you need to do that and
it needs to be get rid of this idea of
permanent bans
like it you know it needs to be like
like the worst case scenario is a
five-year ban
that's still a really long time but most
people who got banned for like learn to
code
it should have been a month yeah like i
mean honestly you shouldn't get banned
for saying learn to code
but if it was something like we've
deemed this to be harassment then come
on
a lifetime permanent ban well more's
coming
so look we have this video from from
james o'keefe it's not the craziest
thing he just basically says
we're focused on one account trump right
now but this is going to be much
bigger than just one account and it's
going to go on for much longer than just
this day
this week in the next few weeks and go
on beyond the inauguration
dude everybody just stop using twitter
man
i'm i'm really like i i guess there's a
reason to use it
um i've said many times in the past i'm
gonna stop using twitter
i still use it but i just don't care
anymore so i just do a lot of trolling
you know i i love watching michael malus
on twitter i learned from the best
he's the best he's just a stroller yeah
yeah i've seen really good trolls but he
really knows how to make people just
like brains
crack and so i just put out tweets that
i think are funny
and i don't think about it anymore maybe
that is part of the problem
though because then a ton of people are
like yeah but then i'm gonna follow you
because you say funny things
and then people react because they're
dumb and i'm like yeah
yeah i should probably just stop posting
tweets you know you know what i do like
a lot of the opinions i put on twitter i
just say in my videos anyway
this twitter doesn't even do anything
for me it's just pointless
like you know what man i get there's a
lot of people who
really want to get more likes and more
shares and more followers
i i don't care about that i mean i cared
about it when i first got started and i
had that first experience
of going from like 800 followers to like
5 000 and it was a weird thing having
people talking to me all the time
getting hit up i was like what's
happening and then i remember this is
back in 2011
getting the first super stressful
anxiety from seeing like 30 tweets where
they were like tim pool's a fed he's a
cop and i'm like what's happening i'm
being inundated with all these tweets
and it was freaking me out and i'm like
i don't want to look at this and then i
just like kind of thought about it and i
was like
i don't i don't even know these 30
people yeah like i looked through i was
like hold on hold on wait a minute how
many people are insulting me right now
i went through it and i was like there's
not even that many people and then i
thought about it just stopped caring
but i took the platform seriously for a
long time i would live stream out post
news
and then i think maybe like was a year
and a half ago or so i was just like i'm
not going to post my videos anymore
i'm not going to treat this platform i
actually deleted the app from my phone
and then i thought about i was like you
know i do like using the app to follow
the news organizations and certain
journalists so i should probably still
have it
and that's when i flip to just like just
posting nonsense for fun well the sad
thing is a lot of people
are obsessed with it and it's their
entire existence and it's also their
entire identity
and when you see individuals like that
it's like okay
i mean and then we also have to
understand the other spectrum here your
emotions could be manipulated by bots
or by fake government sock puppet
accounts that could manipulate your
feelings and emotions based on what they
say
that's why i think it's really smart
what you did with your website uh trying
to get
your kind of crowd on your platform
where you have contacts with them that's
one of the reasons i've been
setting up a similar system and
collecting emails on we are change.org
because i understand
that that once i have the actual context
once i have one-on-one communication
with my audience i could open up the
comments i could have an honest
conversation
that there is no middle person and i
think we need to tell people to do this
more and more get your own lists make
sure there's no middle person standing
in the ground that could
that could decide what you get to hear
who you get to
talk to because when you look at the
algorithms they are
programmed for a specific outcome but
once you got one-on-one email
communication emails still could be
rigged in many different ways
especially with the spam box but it's in
my opinion one of the best things we
have right now and we should really be
taking
advantage of it think about this man you
know so uh i've got on this channel
we're at like 900
and something thousand subscribers you
guys are awesome thanks so much for
subbing and we're really close to
getting that gold medal but i got two
other channels over a million
so there's probably some overlap you
know some people subscribe to all three
but there really are a lot of people who
aren't who are subscribed to only one or
the other then i got
you know uh 790 000 or so on twitter and
i'm like man
if i could get just 10 000 people
giving 10 bucks a month we would not
have to worry about any of the
censorship
out of the millions of people just 10
000 people
i mean man for that matter even if it
was just
5 000 people that's crazy and you know
what
the crazy thing is the leftists do it
they do it they do it really easily
that's why some of the biggest podcasts
in the world i'm not going to name any
of them but they make like
they're making like 150k on subscribers
every month
and i see that i'm like they don't care
about what they say
because they know they're directly
funded by the people who like their
content
whereas i made the mistake of just doing
a traditional ad model
which means if i get nuked business over
so i was like we got to start this i
should have done it a long time ago
and now we really got to start pushing
it and making that the core function of
what we do
because if you're you're you're better
off with
10 000 dedicated fans giving 10 bucks a
month because then you can
you can really run a biz with that kind
of money yeah when youtube demonetized
me at first i was like oh my god i'm
going to lose all my money this is
horrible
and then i'm like well i just got thrown
into the deep end i could sink or swim
and i was like let me swim and i set up
a similar system that you have
and i you know i started making shirts
and and again
people need to understand one thing that
you bring up is this extremely important
point
that you as the individual watching
right now have the ultimate
power to decide what your attention what
your votes what your dollars what your
clicks
what prevails if you want the nonsense
to prevail you're going to focus on the
nonsense and give your energy and time
and focus on that nonsense
if you want good things to prevail
you're going to make sure those good
things do prevail
by investing in them we used to do uh
when i used to do fundraising they would
have these little gimmicks where they'd
be like it's 10 bucks a month
not even a cup of coffee every day so
you know what you do
instead of getting that that venti you
get a grande instead and boom you're
supporting your favorite creator at the
time we're talking about nonprofits so
we're like you want to save the
rainforest right
forego one cup of coffee per month boom
you're saving the rainforest you got to
do what you can
to to to help support the things you
like but but uh
i really want to stress that point out
of the you know combined follower
account of all of my socials around like
four plus a million we only need ten
thousand people
and then we're totally financially
independent from this entire system but
i'm talking like
ten thousand people at ten bucks a month
is expansion territory
like new buildings new staff new news
that's the territory we want to get into
now with jack dorsey saying it's going
to keep expanding
i'm thinking maybe i should just stop
using twitter
look i like the twitter list i've
curated of people i follow because i got
a good balance and i use it for
news aggregation getting banned would
kind of
you know hurt my ability to follow the
news so why why why why bother even
contributing
to the news like given the fact that the
subscription model and this this ad
model is getting more popular with like
people on the left
and people on the right do you think
like the concept of like the public
square
is going to be like outdated or is like
even it's like overrated twitter twitter
destroyed it
yeah twitter twitter really is is the
place to destroy it because that's where
up-to-date political news happens yeah
you know facebook is like a bulletin
board where you walk up and you
put something on the wall and you walk
away uh-huh twitter is like the people
standing there talking to each other
each other yeah
so them taking the power and giving it
to the left and then the left acting
like it's not happening
is what's the end of even moderate
views in this country when do you think
that switch happened though i mean it's
gradual it's grains of sand in the heat
right so
over time twitter's become more and more
prominent i think donald trump played a
huge role in it
donald trump should have gone to another
platform he didn't do it do you think
that was like the guilt for them like
yeah we did not
we the fact that we covered the
wikileaks story and all this
all this like gave credence to this guy
and now he's in
like the president's seat like that's
like the kill yeah yeah maybe but
the real issue is that jack dorsey seems
to have never talked to a conservative
before
yeah so like when he went on the joe
rogan podcast it was it was
aptly and accurately pointed out by many
conservatives they were like
why are four liberals sitting in a room
talking about banning conservatives and
two liberals are defending conservatives
instead of having the conservatives
actually defend themselves oh that's a
great point
you know joe asked me to come i'm
admittedly a liberal
on on most of these issues but i believe
in freedom yeah i don't think the
current version of liberal is even
liberal these are like authoritarian
progressive left yeah but it's not even
you know the people who say they're
liberals are just tribal democrats
you know so that we might agree on some
economic issues but they don't agree on
freedom
yeah so it really just comes down to the
fact that jack doesn't know
he lives in a bubble a far left ultra
progressive bubble echo chamber yeah and
he thinks it's normal
yeah so he's like when he hears a
conservative say i think uh you know
her conservatives say we need to have
better uh border security to make sure
that we can protect our jobs he goes
it's like actually that's most of the
country but you live in a bubble
so i'll tell you one thing man when i
when i heard
there are some some leftists who have
shows where they've got like 30 or 50
000 people giving every month and i'm
like
that one leftist dude is a millionaire
because leftists are collectivists
yeah because when the when when the
authority says rally to me
and they raise their fist they all say
yes it's what they believe in
conservatives don't really do that they
serve as more individualists
so i think this is a big weakness for
conservatives you know
crowder has mug club so he's absolutely
been on on on the game with this
and you think about it when youtube
nuked him
he was fine why he's got a mug he has
the backing of the muffins yeah
yeah and i was like man what am i doing
i was like we really got to make sure we
have that barrier
i've i've taken donations from people
for a long time i never like
very like stress it to an extreme degree
but this is this this is the the legit
reason
to make sure that we're hearing the
words straight out of jack dorsey's
mouth
the bombs are dropping and then we're
seeing it um right after the
january 6 instagram actually started um
deleting a lot of like photojournalists
like a lot of their posts just from the
sick so now if you just report the news
like straight
to me dude you're now gonna get shadow
band sensor you're gonna get warnings
gonna get all this stuff
uh deleted so first it starts off with
trumpy then now we're just gonna we're
gonna start moving into the people who
just do straight news like people that i
literally just
do news i was seeing them get their
stuff nuked on instagram facebook yeah
and then we're gonna see it on on
twitter too so
i mean this is just it's horrible i mean
the thing is for me is it's easy like i
would love to be in a position to be
like i want to delete twitter but
i'm so on the on the up and coming where
i need twitter for
the type of work that i do you know
field correspondent journalism so very
tough spot for people like me right now
and it's just like what you know
what do we do at this point but you
don't you don't have to contribute to
like the core of what's causing twitter
to be a problem you can post news
you can follow news i'm talking about
you know when i tweet
jokes or trolling it it gives people a
reason to use the platform
so for me i'm kind of like maybe i
should just use it as a
business vehicle of reading what people
are talking about you know
i used to do segments where i would see
someone like do a twitter thread and
then i would argue
a little bit and i was just like i don't
care about these people i don't care
about taking some verified blue check
with a million followers and then doing
a video where i'm like well here's why
they're wrong
i'm not interested maybe sometimes but
i've tried to get away from a lot of
that stuff and just keep focused the
news
and i think the more we keep our
addictions to twitter for whatever
reason
then you know it's just going to keep
this this is going to keep dominating
the system
and it's it's our collective voices
using the platform that gives jack
dorsey the power
to decide what the culture is going to
be in the next decade or so you think
it's why gab is great yeah and every
year gets
gets a little bit um like from my
perspective every year it was getting is
getting worse
on twitter because last year one thing
that i was able
to not me like report on a lot but i was
able to use my platform to communicate
with these journalists is um
is it uh last year and it's just still
the problem now is the problem with the
mexican cartels
in mexico so one thing that i was able
to discover with twitter is twitter
actually at least last year they were
letting a lot of those videos
just flow on and we were able to show
the american audience like hey this is
what goes on in mexico with the cartels
and stuff but then as soon as the new
year started
um they banned all these like violence
videos which i get
but i still think i still think that
twitter needs to respect the newsworthy
of the of these subjects because now we
don't see them and also too around i
remember
um in the beginning of 2019 you can't
even see these videos now
is when iraq was starting to protest you
would see how the government was
doing the internet blackout in iraq they
were killing a lot of their protesters
who were unarmed you got to see that
stuff on twitter
and as soon as 2020 started they don't
even let that stuff fly so it's like now
we can't even inform
the public of like these real situations
in these countries too well another
thing you really need
to understand here is that they're
ruling with fear they're setting up this
chilling effect look
innocent people got hit who just report
on the news
they get taken away and i wouldn't be
surprised if potentially
this is just my theory jack dorsey
released that video himself
to to set up this chilling effect saying
you better behave you better do what we
say
you better censor yourself or we're
going to totally cut you off because
more cuts are coming
and they knew what they were doing
because when we look at the onsen of
like
google and google video youtube blip tv
whatever
it was it was first new kind of software
new systems new websites that were very
kind of
out there in the open if you liked the
video if you subscribe to a channel
you would actually see the channel the
the channels that were most viewed were
listed
these are the most viewed channels of
course a lot of anti-establishment
anti-corporate
dominant stuff came up and it scared the
other
jesus out of people and they were like
crack dealers because that
that little whiff of freedom was a
little crack you know
in new york city when i grew up crack
dealers would give crack to people who
were downtrodden so they get for free at
first
they would get downtrodden they would
they would take the crack they would
then they would become crackheads and
customers that they would of course
uh use and abuse yeah always they always
had the free samples
for a reason they did the same thing
with social media
and that's why some people akin social
media addiction to alcoholism even
there's been some studies showing that
it could be even more severe than
chemical dependency
your link to this cyborg machine
that is literally programmed to keep you
addicted to it as they even
work with gambling institutions to try
to gamify everything so you're stuck
into the gaze blindly looking giving
away your soul to it
that's why they never got rid of
follower count
or retweet count they talked about it
and they never did and the reason is
they know what drives people to use
twitter
is earning points pieces
like that was the whole concept of like
social dilemma like they shed
a really good light on it like this is
actually designed
to keep your attention like everything
about it like the fact that
when you like scroll up and it kind of
like gives you like a bounce effect and
like kind of refreshes that's like the
lottery machine they work with the top
psychologists exactly
psychology experts in the world to try
to get you hooked on it like
like you're a drug addict and that's why
luke and i i know luke has actually said
this before so it's not in the new but
that's why
uh if you look at like teenage girls
their depression is the highest it's
ever been because that endorphin like oh
my god he liked my picture so what's up
friend
now that we're we're constantly bringing
this up uh go to timcast.com and become
a member
because i can't imagine they're going to
be happy
i mean yeah but it's about it's this is
i'm loving this segment i'm like yes yes
let's explain to people the very serious
threat we're
facing and why i'm like we need to build
this this this backboard safety that
kind of deal
because my facebook is effectively shut
down
i'm allowed to post but i can't monetize
and
they've they've shadow banned basically
so it's effectively done why
because on january 6th i made a video
saying here's what's happening
man this is crazy look at this look at
that look at this that was it
can't allow it news is not allowed so
gone
but i want to talk about something in
this you know they're they're
when we're talking about addiction there
you got to think about what the
addiction drives people to do to fulfill
that addiction
we've all heard the story about the dude
willing to go to great lengths to get
that next hit
you know they make tv shows about it if
people want drugs
they'll sell their possessions they'll
rob from their families they'll do
uh things with people they wouldn't
normally do
because they're desperate for that hit
that brings me to this next story
this is from azcentral warrant issued
for
a warrant issued for arrest of far-right
streamer tim
baked alaska giannet after he violates
release conditions
fails to show in court now for many of
you you may not know who this guy is
many of you may but uh he's been
involved a lot in politics he used to
work for buzzfeed he then worked for
milo yiannopoulos
and uh i've actually interviewed him in
the past he was associated with
right-wing groups and then alt-right
groups and then argued
he wasn't all right and then it goes
back and forth but the reality is i
think what we've learned from his time
at buzzfeed
his attempt at being a rapper is that
he's actually just driven to get likes
he's driven to get attention on social
media and i think his story
and everything this guy's done he was
he's in he's filming himself
storming the capital he's pointing the
camera and he's like trump's going to be
really happy with us and he picks up
his phone or whatever and he's making
jokes he's gone
so far off the deep end there are a lot
of people right so
before we read into this i want to
mention joey salads right you guys know
joey sally yep
we had him on the show he he made a
youtube video where he hired black men
to vandalize a car with trump support
like trump merchandise in it
and what he did was he was like i'm
going to leave this this car with trump
supporter stuff in it
in this neighbor and see what happens
and the next scene is black men damaging
the vehicle
somebody in the apartment above filmed
it and saw what
he what joey had done and then right
when he released the video
sent the footage to i think h3h3 and
then busted him staging this attack
which was and many many people said it
was racist or fueling racism whatever
you want to call it
and so i snapped at the dude i was
yelling at him i was like this is
disgusting behavior
but joey you know he apologized most
people just don't give them a chance at
redemption but i've always said if you
don't at least let someone
try to do better they won't they'll go
the other direction so i had a
conversation with him and
what he said to me what he said to many
other people is that he didn't realize
how far he had gone
in making this content and chasing after
the money and the views
now you look at someone like baked
alaska he's got no limit
it's all about the next one up to get
that hit to make that money to get those
likes to get that traffic
and then he winds up listen here's the
story i'll give the gist of it
he jumped bail according azcentral to go
to dc in the first place breaking the
law
he breaks the law going in the building
and films himself doing it
and then he doesn't show up for court
and his lawyer can't get a hold of him
he has been driven to the extreme and
chasing after this night the crazy thing
he got started at buzzfeed ben smith
former editor-in-chief
i believe was the one who hired him he
wrote an op-ed about it you take this
young person
you put him in this environment where
you're like get those likes get those
likes this is what buzzfeed's all about
get those shares get those shares
and they're gonna and i don't think
buzzfeed gets to absolve themselves the
responsibility
of what they created in this dude well
if you look at the inner workings of
buzzfeed they actually have entire walls
dedicated to how many licks uh likes how
many hits
an article gets uh don't look at me like
that lydia
i know i did it was a fraudulent slip
but but they incentivized
potato potato they incentivize i'm
polish and dyslexic they incentivize
literally uh
get as many hits as you can so is it
fair to say that that baked alaska is a
product of buzzfeed and buzzfeed
radicalized
yeah i i don't like speed radical i
don't think i'm not trying to make a
joke about it though it's true
i don't think he is i think he was
already like that because even before
the whole capital thing i would actually
see some of his videos just on twitter
with the circulating it'll just be him
walking into like a grocery store with
no mask
and people telling him where to mask and
then he'll tell him like the buzzfeed
stuff was
years and years and years ago nobody
knew who he was when he worked at
buzzfeed
oh yeah i know and he gets hired for
this job where they incentivize his
behavior bro
those things you do that shock content
you can make money doing it
in that system and like there's no
wonder that he right now like that
became his whole model well let's let's
read this so uh this is from a central
they say a scottsdale judge issued a
warrant for the arrest
of far-right social media personality
tim baked alaskagnet
after he said jeannette violated
conditions of his release by leaving the
state last week to go to washington
where he apparently live-streamed the us
capital riot
gina already was facing misdemeanor
charges of assault disorderly conduct
and criminal trespass in scottsdale city
court
after police allege he refused to leave
a bar and then
pepper sprayed an employee he had been
released in that case with the agreement
he not leave the state by the court's
permission didn't he film himself doing
that yes
yeah he filmed himself on on on that
d live live stream yeah picks up
somebody yeah picks up the picks up
the senate phone and acts like he's like
uh talking to donald trump it's just
it's an all bad video
so they say judge james blake was not
pleased the 33 year old jeanette chose
to skip his court hearing without
explanation
and even janet's attorney zach thornley
was unable to reach his client on the
phone
during the court hearing now my
understanding is that d live banned him
yeah
he is look i remember when he was
posting these like ironic nazi jokes on
twitter
and then he i interviewed him and he
said look it was just supposed to be
edgy and it was supposed to trigger the
left he was freaking out
and it was a mistake and i was like okay
and then he does it again and again and
again and then he and then he gets
banned
he had like 250 000 followers yeah
and he gets banned because he just would
not stop
he was constantly trying to one-up
everything so i was like okay dude was
clearly lying to me
now we see where he's gone since then it
is just a constant one-up
i tell you man when you're an addict and
you are chasing after that hit
i don't care if it's social media or
drugs this dude is now a fugitive from
the law
isn't it crazy how like we we we talk
about social media being addictive how
you guys are mentioning that
luke you said it was like alcoholism
something crazier than that
here's a guy now who his lawyer can't
find him and the judge wants him locked
up
and he's probably he's probably facing
oh federal charges for the right
this this we're talking about that's
that's scottsdale arizona
that's arizona right that's not we're
not even talking about what's gonna
happen with the fbi
federal prison to own the lips no but
for the likes man
this is the important thing right i
don't think baked alaska is far right
i think he's just he's like a social
media saying whatever he can to whoever
will listen
yeah and social media prostitutes here's
here's what happened to a lot of people
on twitter
they would post a meme and if it was
like left or right probably right
because most memes are being produced by
the right yeah they get a ton of likes
feels good a lot of shares more
followers more followers so they one up
it
and they chase after it with no end
no point of self-reflection at no point
do they say hey whoa maybe that's too
much
like joey salads did only until he got
caught and shut down to joey realized
like i didn't realize what i was doing
and now he's stopped and now his videos
are like hokey pranks with his
girlfriend where like he's nicer
he puts like sprays with time i don't
know it's really quick uh hey
attention is a hell of a drug yeah tim i
don't know if you ever
um or luke if you guys insulting if you
guys heard of this uh social media girl
she was it was a couple years ago
her name was um because now that we're
speaking about this just
brings me up to my head her name was
little tay and she was like yeah she was
interested she was like a 10 year old
girl
regular girl and her brother tried to
groom her to be this like
fake social media rapper and basically
she would
her videos would be like you know you
put the camera on and she'd be like i'm
a little tay
i'm 10 years old and she just have money
she's like i'm rich this is my ferrari
and she just got into it and then i
think i forgot what investigative
reporter
was able to pull the videos where her
brother is literally training her behind
a green screen like she's just like a
regular 10 year old she's like what do i
say
say it like this be more ignorant and it
was just now now that we're speaking
about that addiction it was like
it was that too like they were just that
likes the likes that likes
fake images there was cases of of people
abusing their children for
youtube videos yeah exactly uh that you
know philip defranco even called out
and brought to everyone's attention that
was able to actually take them down
because if it wasn't for individuals
like philip defranco to to actually
address this no one would have known
they would have kept growing in numbers
but he and i think a couple of his
viewers took all the videos and they
made a compilation a compilation
and it it was akin to child abuse of
them putting their children from the
camera making them fight
doing everything for attention slapping
them hitting them i mean it's just
absolutely they're crazy how low people
will go there was a video on youtube
of a dad giving his daughter a vaccine
and like pulling her pants down and
putting the needle in her butt
and it had like 12 million views
i don't i don't it wasn't in america but
there was this phenomenon that happened
on youtube
where bots figured out what was getting
clicks
and created these insane videos of like
you'd see these cartoon thumbnails of
like
a a guy drinking out of a urinal and
it's for real like a cartoon
and you click the video and it's like uh
what was spider-man joker and elsa
running around with music and then elsa
was pregnant
and joker would have a gigantic syringe
because those were for some reason what
the algorithm was promoting
so these people are chasing after
whatever they can get
the algorithms are turning us into
lunatics yeah i look at i look
dude i get messages from people man i
don't know what's happened to my friends
no joke i have left-wing friends who
think
that i don't even want to get into the
conspiracy stuff they believe but it's
like
you've heard of q anon you know why
because the media talks about it and
they go haha look how dumb the right
wings
right-wingers are but the right doesn't
point the finger at the fringe
conspiracies of the left and the things
they believe
probably because that's not what the
conservatives do they're focused on
government they're focused on
power yeah but because the media is
focused on this this threat of q anon
they don't talk about the left and the
unhinged and insane conspiracies like
we got a glimpse of it when msnbc ran a
segment where they claimed that donald
trump was
a a soviet kgb asset
the soviet union no no joke from the 80s
they actually had a guy on and said we
got to consider that trump may have been
maybe maybe an asset of russia going
back to the 80s
when they were part of the soviet union
dude now that was a glimpse
i tell you man i'm not going to name
some of these people because i got a lot
of followers hundreds of thousands
they've been on twitter the entire time
saying
insane things well beyond what q says
so you hear about this q and on stuff
and they'll be like the nighthawk is is
driving
and silver fox is gonna is gonna launch
the the missile and then we're gonna see
the indictments and it's like it means
nothing
and then you look at some of these
people on the left and they're like
murmurs are happening not the doj
you know uh they're turning they're
revolting the deep state is going to put
you know
bannon on trial for treason and he's
going to be executed it's the same
thing but the media doesn't talk about
it they let they give it a pass
well the mainstream media is now telling
us that the biggest threat for our
democracy
for our existence are people's
individual political opinion
when in reality the threat is the social
media it's leading people to hurt people
it's leading people to exploit people
it's leading people to break the laws
and just in those particular instances
that we noted here
there's so many more there's there was a
case in indonesia where people were
taking puppies
and putting them in horrible
predicaments and then rescuing them and
it was always the same puppy being
rescued after it was
placed there and they were manipulating
the algorithm which that was
incentivized promoted by youtube
just right now when you talked about
that vaccine case i remember seeing on
my
on my newsfeed looking up you know
stories for this particular podcast
i seen a vaccine proposal someone
getting a vaccine and proposing on
social
media to get the likes and attention so
when we look at the bigger threat
towards our existence it's not people
who say stuff on social media that you
may not like
it is social media that is the
existential threat
against humanity just ban all of it and
the crazy thing is ban all of it and ban
us whatever i don't care
humans have lost their minds this is
nuts yeah and i mean
the funny thing is it's not the funny
thing but it's just how media continues
to divide us and
i think i actually heard this yesterday
on on tim's show yesterday was
the populist on the left and the right
agree on so much like if you just sat
them at a dinner table
they would literally be shaking hands at
the end of the day like wow we could
probably take down the establishment but
the media makes it seem like
we're so divided like at the end of the
day if you grab someone from the left
and the right they say hey you know what
healthcare is screwing us over i want to
send my kids to college i want to be
able to work where i want i want to be
able to raise a family on maybe on one
income
we agree on these things but they're
making it seem like we are
are now like in a civil war we're two
different countries it's just i
mentioned this on the show yesterday we
were talking about the show recess the
cartoon
and i figured out who this guy was is
randall weems all right
so this is the it's a cartoon called
recess and it's about you know these
kids an eclectic bunch a diverse bunch
mind you
you've got uh different races you've got
the nerdy guy you got the fat kid
and then like the regular kid or
whatever i don't know but there's this
one kid who would
always snitch to miss finster and
there's a quote
hey let me play or i'll make up
something to tell miss finster
on you and this kid's like hunched back
and he's like a teacher he's always you
know
rattling snitching on everybody that's a
journalist
that's journalist today all right what
they do is they see people posting jokes
and having a good time and they go
i'm going to report you and then they
call they call someone at like a bank
did you know
that there's a guy on twitter who said
something dumb and he's got a bank
account with you
and then they're like uh we we don't
serve them anymore we're going to ban
them
shut down they're fun here's the best
part here's the best part
the show recess is from when i was a kid
right and so i look up this wiki for
recess
and randall weems age nine
however year of birth is 1988. he's 32
years old
that means he probably is at the age
where he would work at buzzfeed
that's right so i'm telling you man
these people these journalists
are literally the randall weems of the
world we were all having fun during
recess playing kickball
some of us were really good at some of
us were bad at it some of us were the
weird loner kids who are hanging out
minding our own business or you were the
kid playing pokemon magic gathering and
skateboarding
but he was the these journalists were
the nasty little tattletails
who were always sucking up to the
teacher and just getting in everyone's
way and everybody hated them
i wonder if you all know the kind of
person i'm talking about you can think
like oh man i remember that
i got one now they work at buzzfeed
carla carlo carla mazza
cocoa
our journalists playing playing the uh
the snitch world but the journalists now
are playing the pr world where exactly
where now a politician would say
something and they just run with it like
what happened what happened to us
holding them to uh you know holding the
powerful accountable
now that we just do pr for them i don't
i'm not going to say the msnbc's a host
name but as soon as
uh biden got elected she she went on
twitter and said oh this is a great day
for america we finally have a president
who doesn't lie it's like you're
you're a news person yeah hold them
accountable so now
yeah so now journalists run run pr for
these people and he lied about the iraq
war so like yeah let's not forget
yeah yeah yeah i mean come on biden is a
bag of lies but if a politician is not
lying
it's not a politician i'm sorry but luke
he tweets black lives matter so it's
okay
again it's okay yeah it's fine doesn't
matter that that we bomb black lives in
the middle east as long as we tweet it
that's okay
you know it you know joe biden is a lot
of things and
it's funny because everything the left
says about about trump you could point
at joe biden
i'll give you some examples you know
what i mean oh but it's corrupt oh we
got china we got
ukraine we got the the bobby linski yeah
but trump is electric old man
hold on there well we got video after
video after video sleeping creepy joe
touching them little girls man
so look you can tell from the media and
i'm and i'm i'm i'm over
talking about it but i have to like let
me rephrase that
i'm sitting in my room you know i'm
doing research i'm reading the news and
there are stories that i probably would
have talked about a year ago
where it's like double standard in media
and i'd be like can you believe this
double standard now i'm like so what
it's life it's the new normal it's
possible we know the media is lying half
the time
more than half the time i mean come on
cnn just had john sullivan as a
correspondent
cnn brought on okay so cnn goes these
are insurrectionist domestic terrorists
now for our next guest one of the
demands a guy who was arrested for
egging them on and inciting the riot
and he's not a trump supporter yeah he
even said he wasn't
and they have him on because they can
point the finger at the right and they
get away with it
that's creepy man yeah hey we're all
gonna be waiting for that update on cnn
that they
interviewed uh a criminal punt i got a
feeling that update won't be coming
well i'll tell you we talk about
journalists sending out people but let's
talk about the real
creepy 1984 stuff his next story is from
fox 13.
teen daughter turns in family for taking
part in capital insurrection
they say an 18 year old girl outed her
own mother uncle and aunt
for taking part in last week's u.s
capital insurrection that left five
people dead
helena duke posted images to twitter of
her mother therese inside the capitol on
january 6th
hi mom remember the time you told me i
shouldn't go to blm protest because they
could get violent
this you tweeted duke in a video on one
of her daughter's tweets
therese duke could be seen arguing with
a police officer
another tweet featured photos of all
three of her family members inside the
capitol along with their names
hi this is the liberal lesbian of the
family who has been kicked out multiple
times for her views and for going to blm
protests
to care what happens to me so because
she has little in the way of financial
help from her family
duke has set up a gofundme account that
has already raised 40
000 oh my gosh i didn't even know that
part of the store okay that made it
hold on can we can we do an inflationary
comparison between 30 pieces of silver
and 40 000.
that sounds about right at the moment i
have no idea how i will be paying for
college as i have little financial
support
i have a dream of one day becoming a
lawyer but i need help to get through
those things
i have to attend college and then go
into the peace corps show it on the
donation page
bravo you have lost your mother but
you've made
forty thousand dollars i hope it was
worth it yeah well let me say something
look people should not have been
storming the capital you know and and
and these people uh who committed the
crimes and you know we saw people die
there
they need to be held accountable but
there's something particularly
twisted about turning in your family and
then
raising money often yeah if she called
the fbi privately
and said i know who that is oh my god
that's still kind of like man it's a
tough question
but you you blood is thicker than water
there there are challenges though
sometimes doing the right thing and
holding those
within your own groups and your own
family accountable when they do
something very seriously wrong
it's another thing to post on twitter
hey look that's my mom yeah
give me money welcome to a brave new
world
well more like 1984 yeah what's what's
your thoughts on this luke says i know
you you've been 1984 man
yeah yeah hold on your thoughts first
broke yeah
i've been there a couple weeks ago it's
more like yeah
okay um i think you know social media
also gives you a false sense of
community
a false sense of acceptance it all goes
along with the trends
and i i i think i and i think it's fair
to say that this person wouldn't do this
if she wasn't incentivized to get likes
and tweets and responses now of course
it's also fair to say we don't know the
exact
relationship they had with their their
their mother or their father
so it's it's not that you know we can't
judge here because we don't know what
happened back and forth but for it to
end up
at at this stage where it's this public
and this nasty
and and the media celebrating it by by
highlighting it and talking about it and
this being incentivized in the algorithm
it's something that's uh you know
awfully wrong in my opinion it is it is
the twisted nature of social media and
the current media ecosystem look at what
happened with um
what's her face's daughter who's uh
kellyanne conway
oh wow yeah yeah her daughter is like
saying a bunch of private family stuff
and the media is basically getting off
to it
yeah and it's like dude first of all i
got to be honest
i look at george conway and kellyanne
conway and i'm kind of like is that real
that's upsetting yeah no is that real
yeah is this like reality tv it's like
big boss yeah no like they're a married
couple one's anti-trump one one's
pro-trump that's like a sitcom
yeah it really is huh he's hating trump
and she's loving it
it's the odd family and their daughter
is like and i have to pounce down tick
tocks yeah she's making tick tocks like
yeah corbin no but how
it's like i find it creepy that
this this kid can get on social media
and
the the big news companies are
celebrating
yeah while they're salivating they see
this little this young this young girl
she's like she was like 15 years old
yeah she was like also like thinking
from their point of view like the kid's
point of view to what luke said it's
like
the sense of community they get from
social media is
way more important than their own family
yeah which i think is like the sadder
and the more crave but like in no wall i
would like
think about the fact that oh twitter can
replace my family let alone the fact
that i would make money off of it
yeah so like well that's the more
concerning part it's it's the gofundme
it's the paypal post it's the it's the
raising money yeah it's the interviews
that she gets with these media hits i
think she already did an interview with
like good morning to america
so the girl who turned into a family
yeah so she's she's already you know
going big so i'm about to say this i'm
gonna be speaking for the latinos on
this one
we would never do that because we get a
chance straight to the face that would
be a death sentence for latinos so we
would get the chocolate to the face
that would never there would be a wooden
spoon that's right
yeah yeah you want to give us the indian
perspective from the indian family
perspective we would probably like not
have social media until you're 18. yeah
yeah i love that well in the
cap in in capitalist america children
sell you
yes well that's what it is though the
only reason she was willing to do this
is because she knew she could make money
oh yeah
forty thousand dollars that's a lot of
money
that's a lot of silver that's more than
30 pieces yeah and probably like what a
silver
probably like 25 yeah probably like a
staff position of media matters
yes something like that yeah well think
about it what's what's your family for
right
i mean first of all your family you care
about them they set you straight
but the point the reason why we develop
social bonds
as like people in society is that we
survive
when we stick to our families now here's
this young woman
who's found a better way than her own
family
see what's her parents what are they
really gonna get for her she has a place
to stay or she's ever kicked out she'll
never be homeless
yeah but if she sells them and she sells
them you know for for 40 000
pieces of green paper she gets 40 000
bucks
that's more than her family could offer
think about this if
protecting your family provides certain
resources for you to survive
and selling them out provides more you
can see what some people are willing to
do to get that right
that's twisted stuff man this is yeah i
mean it's a big part of what we've seen
with like black lives matter want to
disrupt the nuclear family
yeah it is all good for that ideology
your cause your cause is central to
whatever you stand for like it doesn't
matter like you're close ties it doesn't
matter what your family is it doesn't
matter your principle
if you're for this cause nothing else
matters well in 1984
you know the fictional book they
indoctrinated the children to be the
snitch
making sure that they would get all the
adults in in trouble for
wrong think and and when you look at the
parallels i mean i think there's some
i mean i don't want to be hyperbolic
obviously there's not an exact
comparison but
there's definitely a slippery slope that
we're heading towards especially giving
all of our power up to these tech
billionaire giants that are
unaccountable do whatever they want
and control the sphere
of conversation but not only the
conversation also
thought when you have that important
aspect of controlling what people can
and cannot think what they can and
cannot see
you have emperor god-like powers that
could influence
children in the most awful god listen
for forgiving ways that you can't even
imagine what do you think
you know what do you think jack dorsey
thinks like if if you were to go to him
and say jack
children are turning in their parents
for money
because of what you built do you think
you would care i don't think he sees
that though
i don't know i'm saying like if you said
it to him do you think he would care no
i don't think i would think we'd care i
think he'd be like well you know
people yeah say whatever they want and
you know we discovered twitter we didn't
invent it
so you know it's a maybe unfortunate
that they did
that's that thing like he he pretends
that it's still a platform
like when it comes to matters like this
but like when it comes to matters like
people on the right saying about things
like then he becomes a publisher about
it
but then i would then i won't allow like
things to like stand in my way
it was you know i think i i'm i could be
wrong but i'm pretty sure they said they
discovered twitter they didn't invent it
exactly yeah they fell upon it exactly
yeah they were talking about how people
started developing a culture on twitter
like the idea of the at symbol
was was created by users who were trying
to make it so when you'd search you'd
see
you could tur at some at someone's name
and the hashtag
was originally so that if you wanted to
find the conversation about it if you
search for just the word you'll get
everything if you search for the hashtag
you get conversations just the
conversations
so then twitter is like oh we'll
incorporate this before you could click
the retweet button
people would just copy and paste and
then put rt and then call
remember those days yeah yeah yeah or or
and they would do mt for modified tweet
i remember that because as far as i've
you know since i've used twitter
they've always had the retweet function
but people still did rt and mt
to like share things and there's also
like instagrams doesn't have this stuff
so their perspective is we didn't do it
don't look at us we have no
responsibility to destruction of the
human mind and
human society or they like it i mean
look if you want to reshape a society
you need to break it down first
and that's happening whether it's
intentional or not i'm sure there are
people sitting back
it's a good thing let it fall apart i
know for a fact many far leftists
have been talking for some time about
tearing it all down so they can rebuild
anew you know we're down with the old
and then they can make their their new
glorious secular heaven yeah
well whatever they think is going to
happen yeah but uh there's a there's a
funny comic you ever see that you see
those comics where it's the guy and he
says oh no all the time
yeah yeah there's one where he's like in
his room and he's like i want things to
be different and the next one is him
smashing everything with a baseball bat
and then the next one is everything just
jordan he goes oh no different from one
yeah
right exactly so you get these people
who go out and they're like i want
things to change
smash fires and you're like
congratulations you got change and now
it sucks
yeah like like a like a mother-daughter
relationship like that's gone now
like what's going to be like
thanksgiving for that kid they don't
care because they have their dopamine
hit because
but i'll tell you something she's going
to be an adult and she's going to have
no family she'll be all low
and she'll be and she'll be in like an
old folks home you know what's really
going to be interesting too about all
this
our parents can rely on us but
millennials aren't having kids anymore
nope like
the the the child like the birthing
rates like gone for millennials
where where where are all these
millennials gonna do when they're older
you know look these regular these
average people are gonna find themselves
with limited or no savings that's one of
the reasons yeah melinda don't even own
anything already
they're not going to own anything you
know what the average net worth of a 28
year old is
this is outdated it was a couple from a
from a year two ago
negative one thousand dollars wow you
know the average net worth of a 30 year
old is
40 grand thousand dollars oh boy and
then from there
it goes up to like 12 000 and then 33
year olds like
you know and we're just talking about
the states right yeah in the states okay
it's old data and my numbers aren't
completely accurate but it's like around
30 is when they finally
get out of debt accruing wealth wow so
these these people they're not having
kids they're not doing families they're
not making money
i can understand why they don't own
anything they don't own anything they're
renting
and they're going to be 80 years old
renting and then they're going to be
like
put my parents and there's not going to
be anybody to help them
they're not going to be able to afford
it they're not going to have any kids
there's going to be a lot of cats
yeah but it's a cat going to wipe your
butt probably not is the cat going to
help you in your wheelchair down the
stairs
take you out to the you know get
breakfast or he's gonna sit there
wasting away
and another factor too tim i think what
we're seeing with the with this pandemic
and something that we've already been
seeing
with the millennial trend is we're
actually gonna see less families with
the millennials so
we're not gonna have that structured
family mom and dad at home
working and just having that i think
we're not even gonna have that so
i would expect as we kind of keep going
on that crime is gonna keep going up
divorce is gonna maybe people are
getting married less and
yeah the whole family structure in
america just seems like it's becoming
like this old idea now now it's radical
to be like
i want to start a family and you know i
want to have kids and stuff that's just
that
that that seems radical now it's and
they're really we need the really scary
part is is there's a lot of undertones
there's a lot of propaganda
subliminally especially in hollywood
incentivizing a lot of this stuff trying
to make it popular
popular trying to glorize it but in
reality it's going to cause a lot of
human suffering
and it's going to make a lot of people
dependent and weak
in a way that they could be taken
advantage of by some of the same special
interests
according to my own personal opinion
that that will dive
in on this forsaken person who's
downtrodden
who's downtrodden by the ideas that they
put out that they benefit from that
suffering
so we have to understand this is a big
cycle that needs to be exposed let's
think about these parents
this girl turns her parents and she
makes 40 grand what do they do now
they're they're excised from polite
society they're called terrorists
they're facing you know they're probably
gonna find some kind of charges they
probably can't work again
i mean well they're gonna they're gonna
have to these people won't just cease to
exist
no they're gonna need food they're gonna
need access i think
you know there's there's talk about this
this uh
collapse of the united states i did a
segment earlier china
the people in china are flocking to buy
this book that predicted the demise of
the us 30 years ago
what is a family to do if they've been
removed from everything they can't get
jobs
they're going to find a way and they're
going to find their own
parallel economy to make money
cryptocurrency could maybe help
but that just leads us to this reality
where you're going to have blue states
saying we don't want to work with you
and red state's saying it's fine
i mean think about this this woman's
going to be able to go to wyoming or
west virginia find a job
they're going to be like we like trump
too by all means come here and work
she's not going to do that new york city
true so the the trump supporters and the
republicans and the right
the red states are going to become
entrenched and the blue states are going
to become entrenched
and if you're a trump supporter you live
in new york you're probably already gone
yeah
so we're seeing the ideological divide
is is getting worse
geographically now and we're probably
getting that getting to that point where
things are going to fall apart
so in that sense speaking of things
falling apart
you guys went to california i have this
story here from usa today
they say california is a failed state
how do we know they're moving to arizona
in droves the story is from august 31st
but they say a few things i want to
highlight before we talk about what you
guys because you guys went actually talk
to business owners and people have been
impacted by the failed policies of
california they say california's energy
policies have failed
they say so have those policies to stop
homelessness
harsh pandemic response didn't help move
here
leave those policies at home what
they're talking about now is people in
california leave
they're bringing the politics with them
that destroyed the state
so this is a story i covered quite a bit
ago
there there was uh uh you know the
fellowship of california there was also
the return of bubonic plague typhoid
outbreaks
disease homelessness so you guys put
together
you did a documentary is that what you
did yeah so what happened tim is we
actually
kind of stumbled on this project on
accident um so i i went back home to
to california to my my hometown in
palmdale so i went back around
thanksgiving
and you know being here and um you know
covering politics in dc you do
even though i always hated myself where
he's like you do get stuck in kind of
like a dc bubble you know you forget
how bad the pandemic is for the rest of
americans so as soon as i landed back
back home in california for thanksgiving
break i visit my hometown
and it's it's decimated it's just you
know
unemployment is high most of my friends
their their parents own these
restaurants now they're going out of
business
uh you know it's just it's just horrible
so i i i
was like do you know the unemployment
rate right now in california i don't
know the
unemployment rate but as of right now um
we do have 17 percent of restaurants
across the u.s so about 110
establishments are closed permanently
100 and yeah and um in november the
restaurant industry lost over 2 million
jobs
wow so being in in california i started
talking to the restaurant owners
about the outdoor dining ban just how
they're doing so as soon as i started
interviewing
um these restaurant owners it was
powerful stuff like they would be crying
in my face saying hey jorge
on thanksgiving week we get the news of
the outdoor dining ban
we have to now lay off the majority of
our staff and it's like and what they
made me realize too is like we're not
just laying off
workers these are families that you know
these people have to put food on the
table
and then also kind of being in this
project i got to learn that
a lot of these couples both of the
couples would be in the restaurant
industry so now you have two servers
now let go no help from the government
and then at the same time
since they're in the working class their
kids are at home all day on zoom
their kids depression is up so it's just
this horrible thing so
sonic came down and we were able to
really focus in on these american
stories because like a lot of these
restaurants feel like they've been left
behind
not only that another aspect is they
spend thousands of thousands of dollars
on outdoor dining and just accommodating
to
to california's crazy rules i mean l.a
county was the only county
to do an outdoor dining ban so just in
l.a county that's affecting 30
000 restaurants these people we're told
we're shutting down indoor dining
so they spend tons of money to set up
outdoor dining exactly and then as soon
as they do they go ah
that's bantu and not only that tim the
crazy thing is is evil
the brewery the breweries in l.a county
were already um
they're they couldn't serve outdoors
unless they had a a kitchen
so i was able to interview one brewer
who spent a hundred grand
on the kitchen just to serve outdoors
only for for
two weeks later the county said nope
done shut it down
so you have this massive brewery stuck
on take
out beers it's impossible and it's just
heartbreaking to hear the owners say
we love this business and we don't want
to let people go but at this point
what what can we do we're putting this
tough corner so the beautiful thing was
is that
you know me and sonic really got to
document these stories tell these
people's stories and when we put a
documentary together
it's it we released it actually today so
it's on daily caller um check it out we
worked really hard on it and it really
meant a lot to the to the richer
to the restaurant because for them they
feel like they don't have a voice but
this is the kind of thing you got to
send to your friends who don't believe
you
that's yes the people who think
everything's fine or that that we're not
facing serious trouble
let him see let him see let him hear in
the words of the people who actually had
their lives yes
sorry i know you you got to work on me
when you talk to these people one thing
you realize like the people in dc are
like people in new york or people who
are on media
they have given people this easily
digestible pill which is like a single
variable way of thinking like during
this pandemic the only thing we have to
consider is life saved versus life's not
saved like the only thing you need to
worry about saving lives they don't
consider the fact these
that these people who run these bars who
run these restaurants they have lives
too
like though if you like close them and
then you say like oh yes we are saving
lives like that's not a solution
that's just a lazy way of thinking like
there are other variables to consider
here
like like the waiter he has a job he
probably has a family he has a child
like what about him
that's one factor about it and the
second factor is
like the hypocrisy like if you like
drive like 10 minutes away from these
restaurants you
walk into target where people are
crowded in like gajillion numbers
especially during
holiday seasons and that's like
literally in front of these people like
you can like look out of their
restaurants which are closed and you see
these
like like target packed and they realize
that these
like lockdown measures do not make any
sense whatsoever and the fact that it's
so blatant
is like insulting to them you know i
think it might be a red pill for a lot
of these small businesses
exactly yeah but i think most people are
going to keep voting dee they're going
to walk in and go
democrat and they're going to walk out
and walk away it's going to keep
happening it's not going to stop
yeah look we don't know what's going to
happen either that or like people who
have the resources to leave
will leave like but unfortunately these
people do not have the resources to
leave they have put their lives
savings into you know creating something
out of nothing
and hiring people and like once you have
that mentality which is like
okay my job is to be responsible to like
put food on other people's table like my
waiters my
chefs you have you're living like a
different life you're not living a life
off like a staff ride in a new york
times
who lives in a pot and whose only job is
to ride like you're responsible for
other people you're in
like you're an entrepreneur and like
people do not empathize with these
people easily and the media has done
like a horrible job of translating that
well because they live in earth the
journalists are like that
randall you can't throw their snitches
yeah they they're not gonna come out and
be like oh you poor restaurant owner no
we we already saw one story
where there was a business they set up
they had a walkway and they put a tent
over it and put tables there so that
people could
use their public walkways at outdoor
dining and the journalists snitched on
them
and said we need to inform new york
they're doing this yeah and then the
the interesting thing too tim is in
california you know
i've grown up there my whole life but
when i was growing up in the early 90s
um you know california was a state where
everyone in around the country was
moving to the golden state you know you
wanted to be in california i remember
when i was growing up you know my dad is
an immigrant from el salvador he just
has a sixth grade education
my dad was able to have the family of
five on one income he was a trucker
and you know we would go on vacation we
owned our cars that life is gone in cali
in california it's becoming almost like
a latin america economy where
the the lowest class doesn't pay for
anything because everything's subsidized
um the middle and the working class pay
for absolutely everything and they're
living on scrum
the other ones have to get by and the
rich it's all good for the actors and
everyone else so i
i in the documentary too i say you know
this is the golden state it's now
only golding for the elites and everyone
else is left behind one of the more
powerful interviews
that i got to him is i interviewed a
owner of a pizza
restaurant and when we spoke about the
gavin newsom situation she was just
crying in my face saying it's an
absolutely slap in the face
for him to be able to eat in the french
laundry indoors
why i have to lay off my employees who
are literally making like
13 bucks an hour you know some of these
folks are surviving on like 120 bucks a
week to
having kids i mean depression is going
up it's honestly some of the saddest
saddest things that we're seeing and
we're just trying to focus on these
stories because it just feels like
the average american story is not
getting told and
you know i think it was a blessing for
me to get out of that dc bubble and to
see it and say you know what
this is what i need to really be focused
on is telling these stories and the next
project we'll be working on and we don't
want to get too much input we're going
to be interviewing parents and they're
going to be talking to me about
you know their kids going through this
depression uh indoors um
you know i put out a tweet saying hey
parents reach out to me and
tim i got over 100 messages and this is
kind of the sentiment of these messages
saying
hey i had an eight-year-old a 10 year
old 12 year old they were all a's
athletic now into the pandemic all f's
social anxiety doesn't want to talk to
me
i'm speaking to a dad right now where
his son grabbed his gun because he fell
into depression during his kobe lockdown
12 years old
he shot himself in the mouth trying to
kill himself but the way he shot it
thank god
he's in stable condition we're going to
be interviewing him to tell the story
but
this stuff is tim is just not getting
told in the news and not only that
and um when i was speaking to his
parents now that made me realize they're
telling me like hey jorge i'm making
less money because of the pandemic my
kids are stuck at home depression is up
i'm also spending more on groceries
double because since the kids are home
they're eating more so it's just all
these little things that you you
we would never consider and sometimes
you know look i know what happened in
the capital
obviously that's big news and we need we
need to talk about it but at the end of
the
day
let's not forget that you know average
americans can't put food on the table
and it's not only california it's across
the state you know we could only focus
there but
let's not forget about the average
americans they're getting left behind
during this i was reading uh
there's something a doctor gave an
interview or something where he talked
about he's never seen such deterioration
not just from older folks but from even
kids kids yeah kids becoming out of
shape overweight their blood pressure's
bad
they're like just obese diabetic because
they're not exercising they're sitting
in all day they're not getting vitamin d
and they're getting depressed social
anxiety for these kids yeah they're
becoming like you know
uh just a home body lying around with
bed sores
crumbs on their chest and then they're
supposed to interact through
you know computers man get out of these
cities the best thing you can do i guess
but some people can't do it you're
trapped exactly like like a lot of
people like people like oh leave
california just move to texas like move
to nashville it's like
a lot of people do not have like you
know means to do that and california
let's not forget it's like a beautiful
state
it's like a huge beautiful state where
like a lot of people live and
a huge sloth of population like feel
like they're left behind
just because of the governor just
because of the mayor and it's just like
a harrowing thing to see
and like when you meet these people the
thing you realize is that
like they are so like the fact that
like tucker talks about a lot of the
fact that classified like it is so
obvious to them
that people when people think about
california they think about oh the place
where actors live oh well like
celebrities live
but the fact that they're like actual
waiters or actual restaurant owners who
not have jobs
like that is classified you know i was
thinking something i was like
when i saw gavin newsom doing that fancy
dinner
french longria what was it called french
laundry french laundry
yeah that's the name of the restaurant
it's one of the most fanciest
restaurants in the world i mean the bill
was
400 grand-ish 400 grand
what the bill how much was the bill for
that that's what that's what the pizza
owner told me like the bills should be
like closer to 400 grand like
people 12 people ate there in in vegas i
remember uh shane smith from vice
spent 300 thousand dollars i think on
dinner
but yeah yeah so when i when i saw that
i have never been closer to
raising my fist and yelling workers of
the world unite seriously yeah but but
that's like socialism
but here's what i'm thinking like is
there is there a thing where we can like
unite the workers but not as communists
and just be like yo
these politicians that's the new right
dude that's the new right that's the
populist new riot well like people
realize that we
us being workers have been left behind
by the government and the only like the
way to unite is like not exactly like
following bernie's rule but like what
tucker says
it's like you as a worker have a right
like the fact that
the whole concept of like someone having
a job like the same job at retiring at
60 years old with this rolex
is like outdated should be worrisome
so yeah let me say probably one of the
most bannable things
uh so so let's let's recognize people on
the right should not be voting for
republicans
let's see we see what they do no they
hate their own voters right yeah but
let's also recognize
the left should not be voting for
democrats yep so everybody made a
mistake here
how about we all agree the workers
should unite but not to
change the like not not to make
socialism
just to get rid of corrupt crooked
politicians
and i mean this peacefully i mean we
need to have people come together
a populist movement saying we might not
agree on the economic policy but we can
all agree the elites don't have our back
and are selling us
out yeah and stripping away our access
and our rights and our liberties
and if the workers do unite it doesn't
have to be for communism
it can just be for the american rights
and the right to make a living like
yeah like if i'm being honest i was like
far from being like a
like populist guy like i was like clo i
would be i would say like i was close to
being like a new conservative like
before this year began but like when
twenty paul ryan conservative
but when this year started rolling down
i realized that like
holy [ __ ] this class divide is like so
obvious
and like these like the washington like
does not give
a single crap about any of these people
at all
like if they're like like the the
stimulus thing was like the perfect
example for that like i talked to this
waitress who was like 28 years old
single mother has like a four-year-old
son and she was like the last stimulus i
got was like when everyone else got
there like 1600
dollars like back in like april may i
don't remember like that was the last
one and like
and ever since that i've been earning
200 a week
and like like i have a son who's like
two years old like what about him
you know i think people need to start
realizing you can't count on government
you can count on them to to put the
roadblocks up but not to give you the
food after they they screw you over and
so
i know a lot of people don't want to
hear it and it's maybe easier for me to
say
but we're going back to you know we're
going back in time in terms of our
in terms of look let me stop there we
were in a golden age for a long time
you go to the store you get
cheeseburgers you get pizzas boom just
like that for for dirt you go home you
put in the freezer you put in the
freezer you put in the oven you got food
that's that's easy living you know
people used to have to work from
the sun down just to have enough food to
survive and it was work
non-stop and we're heading back in that
direction
for whatever reason you want to say i
think people need to become self-reliant
independent
start realizing the government's not
going to get your back and even if we do
change these politicians it's not going
to change
anything no no power power tends to
corrupt an absolute power tends to
corrupt absolutely i mean wages been
going down in this country for the past
30 years and they keep going down
life expectancy in in america is i think
it's like where like it's just dropping
dropping down dropping because now
americans have to work more jobs
um we also have the opioid crisis it's i
mean
and then the pandemic obviously doesn't
doesn't help economy
yeah yep back back to your point like
the thing is like
yes like metro metocracy is like still a
thing
and like people should like believe in
it but at the same time people should
always question like this
congregation of powers and anytime
there's like this like unwarranted
like mammoth of power to any corporation
to any government people should like
question that or at least like is this
right that this one company has like
access to
everything that we do like websites
groceries
like flight tickets like everything like
you if you fall out of line
and this company doesn't like it like
that's it that like that's it for you're
banished from like normal society that's
why i think we might be heading towards
peaceful divorce as many people have
called it because like i said
people who can't get jobs anymore
because you know blue states won't hire
them they can get jobs in west virginia
and wyoming and nebraska or whatever
but i guess we'll see how it plays out
we should uh jump over to super chats
take some
audience commentary if you haven't
already smash the like button it really
really does help and we're gonna read
super chats from the audience
we do the show monday through friday
live at 8pm so subscribe hit the
notification bell
hit that like button don't forget to go
to timcast.com become a member
we're going to have some uh members-only
content coming up very soon
and uh some of it's going to be funny
we've got some stuff from when alex was
here making you know
giving you know just kind of
that'll be members only content of uh uh
yeah
of that kind of stuff and we got a bunch
of footage from when he was here so
and our guest too so it really really
does help we're trying to create that
safety net so that we can grow the
business
without having to rely on on these
advertisers and youtube
and if we get banned we'll still have
that site so again timcats.com become a
member let's read some of these super
chats
sam meehan says it's time for a populist
party
left and right the people need to take
this country back from the elites who
have lifetime seats in our government
we can deal with policy disagreements
after what perfect timing
that that super chat was actually from
earlier in the night
jordan jones mentioned that last time i
was this early my wife was pissed my
goodness
a lot of men uh a lot of people are
mentioning oh boy
uh that's uh lou dobbs dropped there's
gonna be some declassifications yeah
bombergate stuff we'll see how that
plays out you're gonna watch it
raymond field says what y'all think is
to happen on the 20th
i think originally i thought we were
going to have some drama and some
violence but i think there's just so
much
national guard you can't even drive
around dc the roblox are insane i think
it's going to be calm
that's just me my favorite conspiracy is
that trump planned everything
no for real like that that in order to
actually get the national guard into dc
you needed an excuse and when the left
came to dc
they actually argued to get rid of the
national guard and that it was wrong
so the conspiracy theory is that the
trump supporters did it so that
they would the left would demand the
national guard that you know what i love
about the conspiracy stuff is that
they say trust the plan but the plan's
been wrong
every single time yeah yeah
so i i got to be honest i i mostly think
nothing
to be honest yeah i don't i don't think
anything i think and i hope nothing and
i hope they they take
the security seriously but i think
biden's going to be president and then
hopefully things simmer down i think
there's still tensions you know an
escalation coming in various forms but i
think the 20th is probably going to be
we'll see though because there's talk
about sunday or whatever and i have no
idea what any of the stuff is
there's other people theorizing that
there might be something like a false
attack but that's just rumor mills that
i'm hearing based on notes
there's no evidence tim i don't know if
you've seen the the little like flyers
going around of saying like hey
storm every capital in the us it was
like i mean the the fire looks super
fake it looks like it has like
just trump supporters are disavowing it
yeah there's no american flag there's no
group
associated to it so yeah we'll see
animal room says where the heck is
crowder
seriously yeah oh i know you mentioned
that last time i was here too
well some people have said that he
normally takes breaks into the new year
this is a weird time to take a break
maybe or maybe he just he takes breaks
and
maybe yeah no exceptions i don't know
though it's been it's been a month right
yeah he's just gone he tweeted something
cryptic
yeah it's really weird
all right let's see we got here student
of history says listening to the video
at 10 a.m stopped listening to a
documentary about sir thomas cochran
and you talked about building culture
and i had an idea of dunkirk style doc
uh docutainment about john paul jones
the og uh revoir b.a
john paul jones was yes he was indeed
petty says
whenever they call something a threat to
democracy replace democracy with either
establishment or international power
yep all right here we go gino bendedo
says why are 20 000 national guardsmen
deploying to dc for an online
inauguration
for perspective there were less than a
quarter than that for fallujah
oh wow that's crazy yeah and you know
there was a lot of apprehension against
the police state a couple weeks ago by
these same
individuals that are now cheering it on
so it's a little weird to have them
congratulate
you know 20 000 plus armed individuals
as a as a large-scale
military mobilization um
yeah that's uh that's uh that's some
people are comparing it to a police
state
yeah insight of the ages says why not
support locals
have dave rubin on uh dave is great dave
is always welcome to come and hang out i
think he's a rad dude
why not support locals uh i'll support
locals in that sense that i think he's
doing is very
is good and great and and giving a
platform to people
is great my concern though is it's still
susceptible to a lot of the same
problems now
with with locals you have your own
stripe account for payments meaning
if you your payment gets banned it's on
you but there's still the fact that
locals is the server hosting the content
and you still have that um potential for
i guess uh failure meaning that
somebody who does something with dns or
hosting or whatever for locals could go
to them and say
we don't care you are associated with
this group and we will terminate our
contract unless you do x
and that creates a threat to you know
the business where
when patreon started banning people what
uh uh
the ceo was saying is like look we've
been threatened by these companies
and we'll have to ban a hundred thousand
people
who are making a living unless we ban
one person
so we have to get rid of the one person
and we don't want to but we have to
and that's the problem with
centralization now this uh locals
i believe is playing on decentralizing
all that stuff but here's what i did
i just made my own website um i know not
everybody can so
if you're someone who's got like a
moderate following and you want to have
your own website locals make sense
for me i run a business where we're
trying to expand and i have the ability
to create my own website and that is
just better for me all around
the only risks i have are directly to me
my my vendors my hosting my domain all
of that is on me
and nobody else so for me that's
preferable
let's read some more oh that's
interesting michelle
uh pate or pate says did you know that
you can no longer look up trinidad shop
shabbat pressure
or and batacaf care both search bring up
absolutely no searches
may amazing no dice says hey luke i love
your work and your shirts i'm thinking
of escaping from long island new
hampshire partly because of you keep up
the great work tim and crew
yeah definitely try to see what
community is right for you
there's uh you know don't rush decisions
do a lot of research do a lot of
homework
and uh thank you really appreciate that
robert galera says tim you've been
talking about reassessing culture i
agree
but how do we do that if we're the
counterculture also
also i'm tragically in california grew
up here all my life i hate what it's
become
didn't vote for this bummer um
i i throw it to daily wire you know it's
the easiest example is the daily wires
doing that movie
and think about in 15 years you'll have
some dude who's like 18 and they're like
what do you want to do it's like
i really want to work for daily wire
productions their movies are awesome
and then someone will say that's that
conservative ben shapiro thing
i don't know man i just you see that
movie they did about this that was so
cool
i'd love to make movies with them that's
what it's all about
so you you create a culture you create
some kind of
inspirational system and a a
a place in a platform and a community in
which you can cheer on young people and
make them feel good about themselves
otherwise they're going to go on social
media sell their parents for for a quick
buck
give them an opportunity to feel good
you need to make that space
justin smith says crowder is controlled
opposition he quietly stepped away at
the perfect moment and will show up once
the bands are over
and still have a spot on youtube also
his rhetoric will change to fall in line
i don't know about all that but uh they
if
i didn't cover what happened at the
capitol facebook would not have given me
the x
so there you go but i don't know if that
says anything about crowder i mean maybe
he just took the holidays off
that's simple solution man it's only
it's only two weeks into january so
yeah that you know i've had
conversations with people who do youtube
who talk about how mid december to mid
january
they stop working because viewership
drops dramatically
it's substantially harder to produce
because most people don't want to and
they're going to their families
and then you've got new years and then
after that advertising rates are gone
because companies don't restart their
budgets and actually start putting money
into ads
until february so they're just like
what's the point
so i'm not surprised i'm not you know i
don't think it you know
joseph lin says hey tim a few of my
friends consider you a grifter and
disregard anything you say because of it
i don't see it but is there anything i
could show them of you to disprove that
notion
no because grifter doesn't really mean
anything like what
what does that mean what are they
accusing me of you can watch the segment
uh
the podcast episode we did with dave
smith the other day where we spent like
40 minutes ragging on donald trump which
was
a lot of ragging on donald trump and
foreign policy stuff
but the problem is if they're calling me
a grifter it means they're probably
getting out of context
smears from leftists and it's like what
do you even do at that point
if they're not willing to listen to a
show a lot of the leftists who watch the
show i did with vosh
actually started saying good things
about me and there was this um
joke thread about you know it was
essentially like which one of these
people is worse and people are like ah
tim's all right he's not that bad he's
kind of dumb though
so when they actually watched a show
because there was a leftist on
and they heard what i said they were
like oh those things actually aren't
true
you know so what they'll do is i'll
quote someone they'll claim it came from
me
there are some activist groups that took
me i said something like
if you were to ask someone who's a white
nationalist they will tell you
this they took the last part and claimed
i was the one
that was saying i was trying to be like
no they'll tell you they're doing you
know they believe in themselves and they
think they're the good guys
so it's it's always it's always some
kind of out of context nonsense
but there's a good reason why there's
almost
no articles that get written about me
because people who actually try and
watch and figure out what i'm saying
after after you get these left-wing
grifters who will like make a youtube
video and they're like here's tim poole
saying this
when the journalists who like writing
smears actually go to the video they're
like it's
not there it's not real and so this
doesn't happen and then nobody writes
about it
michelle pate says luke i was also
emancipated from new york
as well can i buy your shirt anywhere i
would love love it for myself and family
thank you so much for asking of course
you could get it
we are change.org slash
shirts so thank you so much and if you
want
the exclusive i am a gorilla t-shirt
because everybody loves the girl emoji
go to timcast.com click
shop and you will see the brand new
shirt we're gonna have a limited edition
tinfoil hat wearing one as well so you
know i'll point out
luke's shirts are always very serious
and political and how is this serious
what do you say
no no no no no no i mean like it makes a
political point right
mine is literally a gorilla saying i'm
it's meaningless
and then i have the harumph i say shirt
meaningless so if you
the point i'm bringing up is if you want
to have a good good political humor and
political art and support
indentured servitude you can do that
with the shirt things yes uh-huh
i'm brandon says hey tim and the irl
gang do you think we should all go back
to the myspace days
also do you think big tech is just
shooting themselves in the foot
i wonder big take is too big to shoot
themselves in the foot i feel i don't
know i kind of want to open a myspace
account i missed tom
yeah the top eight was cool doesn't just
doesn't timberlake on it now it's not
even the same thing it's like it's like
it's like a music thing we should go
back to my space i like when you click
the profile the song's playing and yeah
you know what i was thinking we
mentioned this before just set up your
profile as a book on amazon
so be like you know you can follow me at
harry potter on amazon
i'll be in the comment section posting
my thoughts and ideas on politics that's
the future that's the way to do it
find me on amazon.com forward slash book
1984. yeah
right there supa bambam says if there
wasn't such a divide in communication
between the two camps maybe the trump
supporters would have would have had
some notice of this person
i hadn't even known he was an agitator
and was ousted by blm until now
exactly so we here at the irl podcast
like to look into the facts and figure
out what's going on and we discover this
guy john sullivan
even the left doesn't like him you know
they're like don't give him us we don't
like the guy we kicked him out
but he probably is still a leftist just
you know violent one yeah radical
anthony zavarro says sullivan is
probably cia cointel pro agent
provocateur
anderson cooper is former c.i.a i am a
guerrilla spin the male vitality
anderson cooper anderson cooper was an
intern right for two
summers yes yeah and then he went to
iraq
i think right well i don't know about
that part yeah he interned i believe he
went to the middle east yeah
he interned twice and then he decided to
go and just do journalism so he made his
own press card
went to iraq to cover was going i think
was it desert storm was it that long ago
it has to be yeah yeah i remember he was
in the middle east with his own
camera eric miller says sullivan is not
left or right he's a mainstream media
intern trying to start his career
i took a break and have been practicing
guitar and making music and maybe your
tier system
could be based on engagement and
seniority yes interesting
he could be the left-wing baked alaska
yeah
daniel maxwell says politicians are
always trying to fix problems that they
created
while adhering to their political
ideology unlike statesmen and public
servants who fix
problems as they are identified by
society for the betterment of society in
spite of ideology
yeah like uh like ron paul i guess is
there can you name anybody else do
like how many people would you consider
to be true statement trying to solve
problems
i'm sorry states people states persons
people states states persons
tulsi gabbard josh hawley maybe i don't
know
yeah maybe i think josh hall is gonna be
a prime minister
he like got himself in the hot water by
oh like with this right thing it's like
yeah before that he was like fine thomas
macy
yeah yeah yeah gareth green says pool
sunbae
to continue our conversation from last
night your view of the power of big tech
ignores the time equation twitter and
facebook did not exist 20 years ago
so what makes you so sure they will
exist in 2040. competition will arise on
its own
in 10 or 20 years maybe technology will
change and and facebook already was in
decline
young people were flinging facebook a
long time ago and they were struggling
and a lot of people are saying facebook
is what my parents use and they were
using other things so yeah we'll see
stefan moore says tim you are wrong
government regulation is not the answer
to big tech censorship
if politics is downstream of culture
they need to re-establish a culture of
free speech
we don't have a culture of freedom but a
right but but of regulation now
no i agree with you that's why i've been
i've been telling everybody the move you
have to make is cultural
if voting isn't going to get you want
because democrats control culture you
need to
you need to engage and create and
inspire
dj white says is it possible that
banning trump just made him more
powerful than he was before in the end
it's probably a pretty self-defeating
ban overall
do you know that they censored hitler
and they imprisoned him
and then someone mentioned this the
other day what is it called like the
beer hall
push was that was called i don't know it
was where there was an attempted coup
he got arrested and charged with treason
and then he came back later
and the the lesson from history is not
that fascists always try and cry
censorship
it's that the censorship did not work so
keep that in mind
gareth green says your whole theory that
tech suppression will destroy the
suppressed opinions
assumes that big tech will not shrink
and lose power on its own the demand for
platforms for the band
means that eventually such platforms
will find ways to beat them and they
will go the way of white castle
wait is white white white castle still
exists i think so
yeah yeah i don't know but uh it's a i i
respect the point
gab.com for instance just built their
own infrastructure so
there you go matthew aslan says tim i
love the show and
and all you guys do i live in
chicagoland and work in a union auto
shop
where almost everyone is a democrat and
trump hater how can i make progress in
getting
getting help to getting kelp to see the
other side of the coin
um i like what fleck is dead like
trump's kind of bad
but he's not that bad right no come on
it's not that bad he's he's bad though
you ever see this video yeah yeah yeah
he walks on people yeah okay guys
that's step one very easy and then
people would say nah he's pretty bad
like what do you think is bad
you know okay that's kind of bad you're
right but it's not that bad
yeah okay that's not that bad it's that
simple i don't know man
talk to people be honest and calm and
rational and then don't start fights
let's see we got here gareth green says
didn't parlor find a new hosting site
anyway it's a try try again scenario if
they failed that just creates the
opportunity for someone else to learn
from it
try again and eventually succeed twitter
will up the way
will go the way of white castle
hamburgers sooner or later
i mean i'm pretty sure white castle
still exists yeah am i wrong about that
i thought so yeah me too
jake degaff says beanie club yes the
beanie club
become a member of beanie club you know
what we probably signed way more more
people up if i called it the beanie club
oh yeah
yeah i heard someone call this place the
beanie compound yeah
well you have a santa beanie does that
count as a beanie the santa hat no
yes it does it's a historic santa hat
andrew mickelson says in the morning
everyone uh
in the morning love the bipartisan media
coverage does anyone else feel like 2020
was a giant psyop
shout out to the no agenda podcast the
propaganda report podcast and
grimerica podcast shout out thank you
very much
let's see we got in this year box of
super chats
jimmy quinto says you think dems want a
symbiotic trade relationship with china
to avoid war and make money
while pushing for war in russia to
secure the industrial military complex
and avoid bankruptcy
yes and it doesn't work that was their
strategy the whole time with china
that by creating lines of trade it would
prevent war when china eventually took
over the
as the global superpower it didn't work
china did not normalize
became more and more authoritarian and
more despotic we just gave them power
publius says so you talked about the
personalities and their addictions
social media
but what about the the addicted users
that are being cut off cold turkey
doctors today do not remember recommend
doing anything cold turkey
that is habit forming yeah what do you
think is going to happen when someone's
got like
all these followers and they get banned
like what do you think trump's going to
do i don't know 88 million followers
he can't tweet anymore nothing
he's going to go to sleep no no
mar-a-lago
yeah yeah he's going to go play golf at
his resort and say i don't care it's
mine
abad says you ask us not to use the same
tactics then what do we do
quit our jobs doesn't do much but out us
and leave us vulnerable
how do you overcome hate when that's
what everyone responds to yell at
someone
be stoic you [ __ ]
i'm not going to read it uh shopping
cart too true
um culture culture and comedy
ryan long is great you guys haven't seen
lioness it's because he makes fun of
everybody and that's why joe rogan's
great and that's why
there's a bunch of comedians that do a
good job because make fun of everybody
is unifying and
you know i look i don't have all the
answers man
jay rico says tim i agree tim agree with
jorge
being hispanic you'd get the chancla i
feel many of us still believe in the
family structure
maybe that will help in our future it's
the sandals so for those who don't know
the hispanic mom fascinating is is she's
the tom brady with the chan club bro it
doesn't matter how far you are she's
nailing yeah
yeah i don't know why it's it's in the
genes it's it's it's it's in the science
all right it's the way it is i don't
make the rules i love it
bob newman says i just heard a yar we
talking about sea shanties
trying to catch up after getting in here
late i love it
yadak says hey i'm leaving palmdale for
texas it sucks here
schooners is closed down i don't know
for how long that's funny palmdo's my
hometown that's where we
shot a lot of the documentary so there
you go what's scooter is that is that a
famous
it's a it's a it's a local bar yeah they
and the thing is too the schooners uh
when the outdoor dining band came for
like the first two weeks they were
defining orders
doing their thing and i think la county
public health basically came down and
said you guys keep doing your thing i'm
gonna put that liquor license so
shady soldier says they already
introduced legislation to abolish the
electoral college
i think it's time to get more aggressive
like shutting down dc
well i haven't seen that honestly i i've
seen some stuff but it never happened it
requires a two-thirds ratification
that's just not that's not gonna happen
yeah they propose stuff all the time
i've seen like some sweeping outright
gun bans
and i'm like it'll never happen because
you can't you would need two-thirds
ratification from all these states
you're not gonna get it
republicans are closer to two-thirds
than democrats are republicans have 30
states right so you would need what like
37.
so yeah not gonna these these massive
changes won't happen
and because of joe manchin they probably
won't be able to pack the supreme court
nathaniel gordon says everyone should
cancel the youtube subscription to your
channel and go to your actual page
on a side note how do you feel about a
independent audit of every government
official oh i'm for it
absolutely like it'll really happen
they'll weaponize and use it against the
politicians we do like
so yeah but that is good advice
nathaniel if you are a member
or uh just want to support me in general
support both
then go to timcast.com and become a
member and we're going to have
exclusive behind-the-scenes content
events and live streams coming soon
just for our members so we should have
one put up tomorrow because we're gonna
hang out a little bit after the show
and create some exclusive content so
let's just do a couple more of these
super chats
bobcat says tim look through history
america has survived far worse than
anything we face today
we're not facing anything we haven't
beaten before just trust that our
founding fathers weren't idiots
i agree but it doesn't mean that we
aren't going to go through conflict and
turmoil
it may be the end of the american empire
in the sense that we have military base
all over the world
america will exist as a country but it
will change we're a radically different
country from when we were founded so
we should still do everything to prevent
it from getting worse
yeah logan luck says here is my stimulus
your work is so important to me
if we had an honest journalism apparatus
the corrupt government could not exist
the msm is the real enemy logan gave us
a 500
super chat that is wow seriously really
appreciate it
uh don't super chat us anything you are
in need of if you need a stimulus by all
means you know
the show does the show is doing all
right our biggest biggest concern
is the ban hammer the purge is coming
jack dorsey said it
so i'm like well look if i get banned
and i'm i'm totally out then
go fishing i'm not going to cry about it
but before that happens i will set up
safety nets and try and make sure we
that doesn't happen to us
track media only says as kelly fails
do you think they will just allow a
divorce they will come for what others
have
uh to support their existence 10 year
tax things sound familiar
far left takes what others have it can't
sustain itself without what you
have yeah california wants to put
it wants to pass a tax where if you
spend at least half a year in the state
no i think it's 60 days or something
they can tax you for 10 years
out of state that's never gonna fly
that's not going to fly but it sounds
like california you said
theft wrong tim theft yeah taxation yes
let's see some gareth green says white
castle still exists but it was once
the dominant hamburger chain before the
rise of mcdonald's
don't like white castle i like
let's see ambiguous castaway says dude
they are censoring you
and other republicans super hard on
twitter check your suggestions on
twitter
i don't care yeah they could ban me and
i'd be like well you know i guess it
kind of sucks
i hate twitter so much oh here's good
news todd harris says only fans didn't
ban trump
maybe we'll see him there soon my
goodness oh that's amazing
all right we'll take just just uh two
more tim pauls
says hey tim we have the same initials
lol will you be releasing more original
music
also i heard trump declassified
obamacare stuff not sure if you guys
covered that
got here late we didn't we we do have
more music coming i recorded scratch
tracks for like six songs
so we'll see what happens when it
happens and then um
i probably have like probably a thousand
songs i'm not even kidding
but you know of that of the songs i
would actually probably want to use
i've been playing music since i was like
seven years old so yes there's probably
a thousand different songs there's
probably like 50 that i think would be
worth recording so
all right last one let's see we got here
silently in atlanta says the force is
with luke
so dog's new name is logan by the way
ever see the movie trial of chicago 7
flip red and blue and take the third
party and regroup roll the effort to
change the culture
and backbone of your republicans well
right on
i think it's really uh uh culture is the
key man
culture i agree i definitely agree with
that what's the name of your dog
i think it's going to be atlas that's
not bad yeah i like that i think atlas
is fair but then people are going to
call her addie or something
whatever yeah it has double meanings
well gentlemen oh yeah
one last thing thank you so much tim
paul's mom for sending me an
alien dog chew toy i really appreciate
it it was really
uh kind-hearted of you the dog loves the
chew toy
and we love it too so thank you very
much and you want to mention your your
fancy shirts one more time
oh yes yes so my email list is on we are
change.org
definitely sign up on there my
independent news organization
is we are change on youtube and because
i got demonetized i started making
shirts
and that's the best way to kind of
support me i think i have over a hundred
shirts now
check them all out on we are change.org
for slash
shirts cool gentlemen thanks so much for
hanging out you want to mention your
socials and your documentary
oh you can just look me up at like
sagnik pasture sagnik basu
and you can find the documentary at
daleycolor.com
yeah i'm a jorge ventura field
correspondent on twitter on ventura
report
instagram jorge ventura tv and like
sonic said
new restaurant documentary just released
it's on dailycolor.com
it's free easy it's not behind a paywall
and once again uh you know speaking from
from the behalf of daily college we
really appreciate
just getting to share what these
americans are going through in southern
california that um
to these owners it was very important to
get the story out there right thanks for
hanging out maybe hold on one last thing
maybe we could do a daily caller versus
temple team uh airsoft match soon
we should live stream that yeah and
maybe do like a whole vlog series yeah
hey that would be
members only content right there for you
yeah we have a
we're in the middle of nowhere a big
wooded area and uh yeah i got some
combat training i want to get out of my
system
it'll be really fun to to do it up with
ourselves and have those two different
teams together and we could even have uh
you know betting odds or
not even betting odds but let's let's
play for a wager of
source yeah cool cool sure i like that
that's a good idea
don't forget you can follow at sourpatch
lid she's pressing all the time you
can't and i am actually now on
gab uh sour patch lids was already taken
i was crushed last night to discover
that so i am real sour patch lids
um lyds there as well so you can follow
me on gab
i have like a hundred something
followers on there and
uh i'm really looking forward to using
it instead of twitter so follow me there
and don't forget you can follow me on
twitter instagram and minds.com at tim
cast we do the show monday through
friday live at 8 p.m
so come hang out we'll be back tomorrow
should be a whole lot of fun
but don't forget to go to timcast.com
become a member because we're actually
going to do another segment
and i think it's going to be you know
it's probably going to be humorous
nonsense yeah because
be honest because we were talking about
something before they started the show
that i want to i want to keep talking
about yes we'll see how it rolls
we just launched timcast.com on on this
this past week
we still got to work out all the bugs so
the secret to starting any business is
to just do it which means
the first bits of members-only content
you're probably gonna get you're
probably gonna be like that is
ridiculous and silly
and then we're eventually gonna get in
the flow of things and figure out the
real value
that we can provide with our guests and
the conversations that are a bonus
i don't want to keep any important
pertinent news information locked away
behind a
paywall because then people who can't
afford it you know there's things you
need to know for your life
but the silly fun conversation stuff as
the bonus for you know those who really
want to support the show we'll have for
you
so again go to timcast.com become a
member and you can also check out my
other youtube channels youtube.comcast
youtube.comcastnews we'll be back
tomorrow at 8pm thanks for hanging out
and we will see you all then
bye guys
you